iz that people can't actually join the
stream.
>> Um, so if you have the
>> I'm going to set up the I'm going to set
up the link
>> or just Yeah, just shoot me the public
link so I can drop it in chat. Um, hey
everybody, we're live. We're going to do
some very fun live coding today. Uh, and
this is an episode I've been wanting to
do for a very, very long time. So, I'm
very stoked to be here and uh I can't
wait to write some code and uh get
yelled at by by Vivov.
>> All right, event is updated.
>> Um I sent them to you as well. We've got
some people in the chat and we should
get a few more coming too. What kind of
hard features are we building today? We
will get to this in just a second.
But this is um like Dexter said, I think
a lot of people underestimate how good
bite coding can be. Uh and a lot of
people view it as like it's great for
throwaway code. It's great for stuff
that we don't really leverage for a lot
of situations,
but I think I've been convinced
otherwise. I've been convinced that you
can use uh coding agents for really
really hard problems in a maintainable
way. So we're going to try that today
live on stream for a problem that has
been aching us for a while. in BAML. And
obviously I know the BAML codebase
really well, but Dexter has no idea what
the BML codebases.
>> Well, we did ship one feature a couple
months ago, but you were driving almost
all of that. So
>> yeah. Uh but even then, like the fact
that Dexter really doesn't know the file
system. He doesn't really know how we
organize code in there. He doesn't
>> I don't know how to run the tests.
>> You don't know how to run the test.
There's a lot. Do you know how to run
the tests?
>> I mean, Claude knows how to run the
tests.
>> Yeah. But the point here is like Dexter
really has almost no information about
what the real system does over here. So
I think a big part of today is going to
be to see if we can go from nothing to
something from scratch. Um but for
everyone that's tuning in um one of the
whole this is a thing that we do every
Tuesday. We call it AI that works and
the whole point is to show shipping
workflows that actually leverage AI in
some interesting way whether it's to
build pipelines talk about how to the
method of building the pipelines or
actually the pipelines themselves but
show real mechanisms for actually
leveraging AI. My name is Fibof. I work
on BAML.
>> My name is Dex. I work on uh code. Oh,
sorry. Do you want to finish the the
oneliner?
>> No, that's it.
>> BAML is a great programming language for
working with uh LLMs and AI agents. Uh,
and it's getting cooler and cooler and
uh, weirder and weirder as as the days
go by. I'm very excited to see uh, what
y'all are solving soon. Uh, I'm Dex. I
work on human layer
>> and
>> this is the part where you tell people
how why
>> I mean I think actually people are going
to get to see it. So rather than talking
about it, I think it's going to be a
really interesting way to just mechanize
how we how you can work with the coding
in in in an interesting way. If you find
this stuff interesting, this is the URL
that you can usually sign up for to see
our Tuesday events. And if you sign up
there, you can subscribe and we'll send
you event invites out every single time.
But with that, let's get started.
>> Um, cool. Uh, I'm going to pull up uh
I'm going to share my screen.
>> Why don't we start with just showing the
problem up front so then people can get
a spec for what we expect to get done
today.
>> Yeah. So right before this, literally
right before this call, I messaged
Dexter a couple of tickets that we want
to get solved. This is a specific ticket
which is in BAML. One of the things that
you can do is you can configure any LLM
you want and with to with retry policies
and all sorts of mechanisms.
Now one thing that a lot of people have
been asking for is timeouts. Uh so we
want to expose that capability so that
users can configure timeouts for uh for
themselves.
As a part of this work, we started
thinking about it. So there's a GitHub
issue that we started with. Then we
spent some other time thinking about the
actual syntax and stuff along the way.
But once we realized what the syntax and
everything was for timeouts, I kind of
just shared all the information with
Dex. And Dex, if you want to screen
share and just show people what I showed
you. Let's start with the GitHub issue
and then from there we can work through
to the docs that we have.
And for context for everyone watching,
like how long have you been working on
timeouts? Well, we thought of this we
thought of this GitHub issue. When did
it when was it proposed? On March 18th.
That was the initial proposition for it
where the idea is that you can say that
there's a connection timeout, there's a
response timeout, there's a total
timeout and then with fallbacks where
like you're actually falling back to a
different model if the first one fails
for whatever reason. Then you want to
have a total timeout for the entire
fallback or retry policy kind of
attached to itself.
And then similarly, if you scroll down
further, uh we realize some problems
with like an actual problem is like you
want some sort of nesting. So it's not
actually like really verbose to write
out. But as we did this, I actually
assigned this to one of the engineers on
our team to go take a stab at. And the
engineer did take a stab at this.
>> Is your engineer code arena bot?
>> No, the code the engineer is not that.
That's like a coding agent that we tried
to go solve this problem. The coding
agent failed.
>> But do you want to show the do you want
to show the markdown stuff that you had?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So um just for a
little more context here and just kind
of make sure I understand this properly.
Um, I'm going to go back to the AI that
works repo and just pull this up in VS
Code. I know I said I don't really use
VS Code that much anymore, but um, in
this today we're going to look at it.
So, because we have lots of good BAML
code examples in here. So, if you look
in BAML source, um, you will have
autogenerated a client's file. And so,
this is BAML code that talks about
different ways that your prompts can
talk to LLMs. And so, we have this thing
called extract date. And you can set a
client here or you can say my what is
it? custom sonnet,
>> whatever you want to name it. Yeah.
>> Yeah. So that is mapped to something in
here called custo I guess this got
cleaned up a little bit. Oh yeah,
there's custom sonnet. So you can have
very basic options like just model an
API key and then you can create a you
know higher level abstraction over it
that lets you do fallbacks and round
robins and retries and things like this.
Um but what's missing in here is is
timeouts. So, if I want to say, "Hey, we
want to try Gemini 2.5, but if it takes
too long, we're going to fall back to
GPT40 Mini because it's better to give
the user something than nothing." Um, we
wanted to be able, it sounds like you
wanted to be able to add a and then VIBO
did a thing that I think is really
really interesting which is actually um
this like reminds me of this technique
that Amazon kind of talks about a lot
called working backwards which is
basically like write the documentation
or write the blog post first before you
go write any code especially for dev
tools. So this is like a preview of a
doc of like how do we actually want this
to work in reality.
>> I did not do this. Greg did this. I want
to call that out. But our team generally
does abide by this philosophy. I think
for AI agent coding, it's actually
really good.
>> And then you had sent me one other thing
with like the clarified format, right?
>> Slack.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> Um I'm going to go through the really
fast just so people Yeah, you may want
to share your whole screen.
>> Um I'm just going to grab that client
because there are other sensitive things
in that Slack thread.
Uh let's see. Okay, cool. We'll go back
to sharing the full screen. Um,
so one thing that we have,
>> let's look at the docs really fast just
so people get caught up on exactly what
the objective is that we're going to get
to. So if you go read these docs, can
you zoom in a little bit, Dexter?
>> Yeah.
>> If you go read these docs, this is what
we're going to want. We're going to want
to add a couple new keys in here that
are like connection timeout MS, which is
like time to establish connection, time
to first token because sometimes the
stream might not come back yet. Uh, keep
on going.
idle timeout where it's like you're
getting you want to delay like the
stream is just stalled out at some point
you want to restart in that scenario
request timeout which is like just a
total request as a whole for end to end.
Uh and then for composite clients like
fallbacks and retry policies and other
things you want to be able to put like a
total timeout. Um the only thing we
didn't like about this is now we're
adding arbitrary key value pairs inside
of here that can be really noisy and
hard to detect and we might have
conflict. So I sent text one more update
to this and this this documentation file
should be updated accordingly.
>> Can you show the HTTP thing that I sent?
>> Yeah, let me just um
>> Yeah, which is instead of doing it some
other way, all the timeout options
should be under HTTP. So all the timeout
options should be under an HTTP key. So
we therefore we don't occupy too much of
the key the key name space inside of
options.
>> Yeah. You don't want thousands of
parameters at the top level here.
>> Exactly.
>> Yep. Cool. So that's the only
constraint. Um
>> I think this is pretty well speced out.
I feel pretty confident that this is
something that we want. Take it away
Dex. What should we do? So
>> cool. So the first thing I want to do is
I want to get this doc as markdown
because this actually serves
documentation is a great specification.
We're saying exactly how the user
experience should look.
>> And so here's our spec. Yeah. Go ahead.
>> I was going to say uh I'll let you do
your thing really fast. So I'm first
thing I'm going to do is I'm just going
to have Claude update the spec to match
the new format with the nested key.
>> And while we do this, one of the things
that we're going to talk about is this
concept of research implement uh
research plan implement.
>> Yes.
>> And while we go code implement this, I
want everyone to uh we'll get to
everyone kind of understanding what this
means
in a second. But the idea is that the
one of the first thing that we're going
to do before we even go do this is first
we're going to make sure our spec is
actually correct. it's properly
specified.
And once we've done that, we're going to
try and do a little bit of work to go
and look through the codebase to be
like, did we miss something? Cuz as
clarified as the spec is, we really want
to make sure it's actually in line with
what the codebase would expect to some
degree and figure out all the parts of
the codebase that are relevant, not that
not that need to be changed, just are
relevant.
>> Yeah. And this is all about context
engineering. And like we'll we'll give
you the high level of this, but if
you're watching this and you haven't
seen that, like you should go back and
watch the episode we did on using
context engineering with coding agents.
Um, but the basic idea is like the less
context you use, the better results you
get. And so we're building our workflow
around what I call like frequent
intentional compaction. And so phase one
is like take the spec and create a
research document that documents how the
codebase works today and everything
about it that is relevant to solving
that problem. And then we use that to
build a plan. And all that means is like
instead of having to research like read
all the code and then build a plan, the
model already has a baked understanding
of how the codebase works. So when it
gets to planning, it's actually writing
the plan in the sweet spot part of the
context window because we always
>> you want to let it rip while while we
talk because it takes time. And one of
the things I want to call out here is
this is like we're literally live coding
all this on the fly. We have no idea if
this is going to work. It may work. It
may not work. While you folks have
questions about this, ask questions
along the way. Uh and we'll try and make
sure that we're it's totally up to date
with everyone uh and their understanding
of it. HTTP key. Um,
what is this issue number?
>> I have no idea.
>> 16:30.
>> Yeah.
>> And I'm just going to commit these so we
can see the diff. And we're just going
to let Sonnet do this one cuz it's
pretty quick. But it's going through,
you can see it's going through the spec
and actually making the changes.
>> Nice.
>> And I'm going to go back to dark mode
cuz
>> Thank you.
>> Yeah, it's just putting all this stuff.
Does this look right to you, Baba?
>> Um, this does look right. Uh BKT is
asking if this is a demo coder. Codler I
think personally I think is a great tool
to do this but really it's really a demo
of the process. You could do this
directly in cloud code if you wanted as
well. Um but similar to how I like to
use BAML to building a lot of agent
stuff because it makes certain things
easier. I personally found code layer to
be a great way to to be a nice wrapper
around
um cloud code because it's for me
slightly prettier and therefore I
navigate the UI a little bit faster.
>> Wow. Okay. This is actually just like a
million parallel tool calls all coming
through Sonnet. So, let me put it on
auto approve and I think we might be
done now.
>> Yeah, it looks pretty good. Um,
let's just have a quick look at this.
Just skim it. This all looks right.
>> By the way, this is one thing I've
actually learned deeply while working
with Dexron on how to do VI coding. Cuz
to be completely honest, I didn't do a
lot of VI coding. And the reason I don't
do VI coding is because like I'm a
pretty damn good engineer and I it slows
me down in the beginning. But the reason
that I was actually getting worse vibe
coded is because I wasn't actually
uh what was it called? I wasn't actually
reading every line of the code. So like
the thing Dexter did here where he
actually went through and opened the
diff to go look at it in a real format.
That is important. If you don't read the
code, you are going to be screwed. So
read
>> you have to read this stuff. This is
this is not magic. You have to read what
it does. The idea is not that like oh if
you do research you it's the magic
prompt that just makes everything
better. This is all about giving you and
I we do all these slides in other
episodes, but it's all about giving you
more leverage, right? You still have to
do the work, but you have to you have to
you you're doing it on on higher
leverage thing.
>> Yeah. So, let's go back. Uh let's see. I
think can you go back to reading and
just make sure it all looks correct.
>> Yep.
>> And for context, by the way, here I have
more context on the [__] codebase. So, I
will read this stuff and be like, is
this good or is this bad? Can you go up?
I want to read that complicated one. the
for fallbacks clients. So fallback
clients are interesting. They don't
actually have uh I don't want them to
have connect timeout, idle timeout, or
any of this stuff.
>> Okay. I only want them to have uh total
timeout.
>> Interesting. Um
>> we should probably tell the agent that
in the dock in the
>> Yep.
>> Yeah.
>> Or the fallback one. What was it?
>> Fallback roundroin.
Uh
yeah, fallback roundroin retries. Um,
>> just the timeouts.
>> Just total timeout. Total underscore
timeout
>> because I think there what was the the
docs basically had it was this one,
right? Cuz this is actually
>> the doc was wrong. Oh,
>> okay.
>> Yeah. Yep. Let it let it rip
>> the lowle.
We'll skip the need for the lowlevel
timeouts to be passed through. Direct
clients are the FT,
etc.
>> Yeah. Cool.
>> Perfect. Um, only caveat D is I think
you should be using your voice stuff
like you normally do.
>> Yeah, I will be using voice plenty
today. When it's names of variables, I
find sometimes the voice one doesn't
have a lot of context. And if it's a
codebase I work a lot in, I'll go into
super super whisper and like update the
vocabulary basically. So like it knows
how to do quad cloud code. It knows the
names of certain people that I talk
about a lot um or even occasionally. But
like I had to put your name in there
because it keeps putting you in as uh
VIBO.
[Laughter]
>> That's funny.
>> Yeah.
>> Um
>> Yeah. And I think one of the one of the
other things that I have learned is like
if you guys are really really vibe
coding and you get the hang of this,
once you've done this a few more times
where you actually can go read
something, I highly highly highly
recommend
um starting to do task in parallel. We
won't do that today because doing 2,000
in parallel while having to talk to the
stream is too hard. It is really hard.
>> But and and like I'll tell you why I
think that works is because your like
points that you check in with the agent
or it's not just you have five cloud two
cloud sessions going and writing code
all day and you have to figure out which
one is which and all this. But it's like
because everything you review is all
kind of shaped the same and you know
what to expect in between your like
prompt sessions and letting it go off.
it becomes easier to like mentally model
what's happening and you don't have to
do as much context switching even when
you're switching contexts. Does that
sound right by Bob? Does that m match
your experience?
>> Uh, I think so. Honestly, it's just that
it seems to work and I have no real
context about why. Um, but it mostly
works and it's like it feels good. I
guess
>> vibes are a big part of this. The best
the best engineers I know like they
don't use evals. They just they just
know what works better cuz they spend 70
hours a week talking to Claude.
>> Okay, so what have we done?
>> Okay, so we have our low-level stuff
here. Yeah, so here's the note that got
added. Um, total timeout present
upperbound regardless of the fallback
change exhaust. No further clients are
attempted. Low-le timeouts should be
defined on individual clients, not on
the fallback client itself.
>> Yeah.
>> Um,
>> that looks great.
>> Cool. Okay. Uh, I'm going to kick off
the research. Um
uh we'll start a new context window for
this one since we've already used about
30%. That's the other idea is like the
goal here is you always want to have um
context and I'm actually going to
I'm going to grab the new versions of
the prompts here. So uh you don't have
to include these in the PR vibe off but
um I'm going to drop them in here. I'm
>> Yeah, go for it. Is it
>> here?
>> Watching someone type feels so archaic
now.
It's like, oh,
>> you need to make uh someone actually
contribute a CLI that does this for you.
>> Really?
>> Yeah.
Oh,
>> I don't have called
>> agents. You spelled agents wrong.
>> Yeah, I know. Something uh in my shell
does
>> I don't have a folder called agents
inside of BAML.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So, we'll make that.
Something in my shell drops the G key
when I paste.
>> Really?
>> Yeah. Oh, you're going to love this. If
you're not using the sub agents, you're
going to this is going to change your
world.
>> Okay.
>> All right. I think we're
>> I'm down. Just merge it. If this works,
you'll get the whole thing merged in.
>> Amazing. There we go. We're We're
calling in installing some agents into
your repo right now. Um, okay. Research.
What is the number? 1630.
There we go. Now we got the good one.
Um, let's read the spec in at spec. I'm
actually going to rem rename this and
research all parts of the codebase that
are relevant to implementing this
feature. Um, it doesn't exist today, but
I just want to know everything where
timeouts are handled. Um, make sure you
don't get into the details of how to
make an implementation plan. Just tell
me all parts of the codebase, how the
testing works, how the integration tests
work, any codegen that's used in the
repo to make this feature work, and uh,
explain it all for me so that uh, the
next agent can pick it up and get to
work. Um Josh asked a really good
question. Why are we making a new
context window? Is that to optimize the
catch?
>> It's actually not about it's not about
that. It's more about like fundamentally
I mean we talked about this last week
when we talked about the entropic models
and where they degraded because they use
the million million token window and
million tok million context model
instead of the shorter context model.
These systems generally work better when
you get the least amount of context you
need to to actually um make it slightly
better. And part of why
uh why we often recommend controlling
the full context window is because a
really really important part of this
whole workflow is actually getting the
system to work well. So once we got the
spec right, all the work that we did
ahead of time in the context window to
make the spec correct can be deleted and
we can just recede the whole context
window with just the right spec. So the
model doesn't have to be confused about
the old spec, what we changed and then
the new spec. It just says purely here's
the spec that I'm implementing and it
forget it doesn't need to remember the
history of what led us to there.
>> Yeah. Because basically the less of your
context you use the better. And so as
soon as like all of the work to do the
writing and building the spec up so that
we were actually upstream of this over
here. Um I'm just going to drop this in
to the white.
>> Uh if you guys want the commands I'll
post them for you guys.
>> Yeah.
>> So we actually were over here writing
the spec. So the spec is part of our
initial user message which is like hey
go implement that thing.
>> Yeah. If any of you want the commands,
uh, they're in there posted in the chat
and you're welcome to go and check out
the cloud code yourself.
>> Yep. They're there. We've linked them
and documented them before.
>> Yeah,
>> I actually and if you all saw, I
actually cancel the old one and because
it was on sonnet and for the research,
uh, I really tend to think that if
you're not using Opus, you're not going
to get good results. Sonnet is fast and
it writes damn good code, but when you
want to reason over a large complex
codebase, you should almost always be
using Opus. it's worth the money.
>> Uh I would say even even differently,
it's more expensive for you to have to
stop and then start again if you get the
wrong result. So it's better to pay a
tax uh the more expensive tax to get it
right the first time around because
large a large part of vibe coding is
actually feeling good about the process
and if you just feel bad about the
process, you're not going to see it
through. So I highly highly recommend
just using the better model at least in
the beginning until you build confidence
about what is working or not. Also,
Dexter, we're seeing your forehead, just
so you know.
>> Can you see my face now? Sorry. It's uh
I have a new AV setup today and uh the
laptop blocks just the very bottom of my
screen. So, when I need to see something
at the bottom, I move it.
>> Yada asked a really good question. Is it
possible the spec and code connect? What
if the code changes? So, the whole point
of this workflow, Yamada, is actually
not to make the spec and code directly
connected. What we're really doing is
really imagine when you're working with
a colleague and you're right and you're
working together and like pair
programming. It doesn't need to stay
connected forever. You just need to be
correct about whatever you're
implementing right now so your colleague
can go write something. And that is
really
um that's really what we're doing here.
And this is this is also why I am very
bullish on like um basically like or I'm
I'm I'm not I'm I'm kind of like meh on
like what I might call um like codebase
documentation and using agents to update
the codebase like using agents to update
the documentation for other developers
to use because I think like one of the
problems with AI generated code is if
everyone on your team is shipping a
thousand lines of code every couple days
because they're all doing these
techniques the research basically gives
you ondemand upto-date codebased
documentation in you know 10 minutes or
so.
>> So let's see let's see what the and this
will be really clear as soon as we start
reading the research and funny enough
you guys will understand a little bit of
the BAML codebase as the research is
done because then you'll be like oh cool
I see where this is relevant and I'll
show you some interesting things that I
suspect the research pipeline will pick
up
>> if it's done.
>> Yep. So these are these are all running.
So you can see it's invoking these
special sub aents that are defined in
the um they're here public in the human
layer repo which is where I got
>> I posted the link.
>> Yeah. So I'm just going to pull one of
them up. Um so we have the research
prompt itself. Um which is yeah this
one.
So it's like the research again it's the
only job is to document and explain. So
it's like analyze the thing, launch
these parallel sub aents, and then we
tell it the document format we want. So
we want some front matter at the top, we
want the user's question and topic, and
then we want detailed findings on how
all of the relevant components work with
really concise. What makes this so good
is that the other the next model that's
picking up in the next fresh context
window doesn't have to search and find
and learn how all this works. It can
just go straight to reading files to
figure out what changes need to be made.
Exactly.
>> And then the agents,
sorry, let's let's look at the agents
real quick. Um, so like the codebase
locator, its job is to document the
codebase, right? And so all all its job
is to just here's this file, here's what
it does. Here's this file, here's what
it does. So it's just finding things.
This is like your super grip. And then
the analyzer's job gets instructions
like basically like find the entry point
to the whether it's an API endpoint or a
CLI or something trace the data flow
from like wherever X happens all the way
down to the database or all the way down
to the external service or whatever it
is and understand how things change
along. And so we use a mix of these
different agents and like the research
prompt uses them de facto and it just
says like hey here's here's here's the
one to use and where you can also steer
Claude to use one of these agents by
hand. Um okay cool we're in the I'm
going to put this on skip permissions
also.
>> We should almost be done. Um Josh asked
a really good question of Manis
recommended keeping the wrong stuff in.
How do you decide to keep it versus to
start a new thread? Well, I think Josh,
this goes back to two elements. This
this is this can vary both based on when
you build your agent and based on uh and
based on what you do with your coding
agent when you're using a coding agent
like using an agent and building an
agent kind of have the same philosophy.
And what I would say is like it really
depends. So for example, let's say what
I'm trying to do is debug. If I'm trying
to if my if what I'm trying to do is
debug in that scenario, it's actually
really useful to keep the history of it
in. But once I have debugged and I'm
moving on to the next flow. So like say
for example the user asked me to
generate some SQL statements and it
produced a bad SQL statement and then I
errored it out until I got the right SQL
working. Well in that scenario it's
actually better for me to delete all the
old SQL statements and only put the
right one in there or perhaps put a
summary of everything that went wrong so
I can show the best so I can show from
the main agents perspective. All I see
is the user asked to do this and I
generate this SQL statement and I
produce the result. On the other hand,
during the process of actually getting
the error, I probably want to put uh you
want you want you mean result instead of
error at the very bottom.
>> Oh, thank you.
>> Yeah. on on the other end in when I'm
not debug when I'm actually generating
the wrong SQL I probably do want
I probably do want all the errors in
there so it can actually debug itself
and get to the right response and I
would
>> so this is like your error compaction
right what is what some people suggest
is if you run three tool calls and then
you finally get a good one the next time
you send a prompt to the model just do
user message and the SQL and the success
because this is a lot of noise for the
model that isn't like productive to the
conversation
and mana says leave this stuff in
because then the model the next time it
goes to write a SQL query it remembers
oh that table doesn't exist so it learn
it's like it's it can learn from what
was in the context window versus like
basically getting errors again
>> yeah but what's really interesting here
though that you could do is can you go
back to that thing is it's not as
straightforward as what mana says what
mana says is leave it in always what I
I'm going to propose a really quick
algorithm that I think all of us can
understand hopefully which
>> I sent you a link to the board by the
way if you want to write it.
>> That's okay. I'll just draw it on your
I'll just reference it on your screen
which is imagine what I did was I did
this and next time that I got a tool
call for a new SQL I actually injected
the errors in only at that time. So if I
get a tool call for a new generate SQL
or create query plan then I show all the
errors that exist in the past five
queries. But by default I don't. So for
anything that is not a SQL generation
command I hide all the SQL errors. For
anything that is I show the SQL errors.
It doesn't
>> if it's calling the SQL generation tool,
isn't it already too late to like by the
time it's
>> you control the tool. So the SQL
generation tool is going to go ahead and
generate SQL.
>> I guess my point is like if you send
this context window in and the model
says I want to run XYZ query
like
>> I I guess I was describing the model in
some other way where like I would just
want it to indicate that it wants to
generate SQL to me and then I would just
toss in the extra error commands in
there.
>> I see. Okay.
>> Right. That's one thing I can do. I
could also update my base prompt or my
like rag system for whatever I use to
describe the SQL tables better based on
the type of errors I do in like a
post-processing world.
>> So if you separated out the declaration
I want to run a SQL query from the
actual writing of the query itself, then
you can inject the errors in between
here.
>> Exactly. And the or or you can inject it
into the original SQL as well into the
original spot from the previous query.
>> All right. Well, this is about context
engineering. It is incredibly off topic.
So, I'm going to jump over here and read
the research doc. Um, let's have a look.
>> Can you You know what you should do? You
should open this in Obsidian and it'll
be so much cleaner.
>> I don't have Obsidian.
>> Ah, unfortunate.
>> But I can do this.
>> Uh, do you want to open the G-grip
version? But you can open this if you
want.
>> Okay, cool. So, here's our research
question. I think this is fine. So,
let's read the summary. And Vibb I say I
don't know about BAML. And this is like
when you're doing this stuff, you should
always have at least one person that's
an expert in the codebase cuz you need
to be able to read this and make sure
it's right and nothing's missing. So by,
I'm going to ask you to read this and
tell me what's what's missing or what's
wrong.
>> Um, this looks mostly correct. Yeah,
there's a new error. Testing. Okay, go
down. Um, that is the right file. We do
currently have hard-coded timeouts that
need to be plumbed through.
>> Okay, cool.
>> Yeah, that that's what I was expecting
it to find. If it didn't find that, I
knew it would have messed up cuz I know
we have hardcoded timeouts. I don't know
where but I know we have them
>> special AWS client handling
>> because AWS does some weird stuff with
it
>> and then WASM disables timeout. That is
correct.
>> Okay.
>> U Can you go up? Sorry, I can't read
that fast.
>> Publishing API publishes. Yeah,
publishing timeouts. Publishing and
tracing timeouts don't matter for this.
Ignore them. They should not be
configurable.
>> Okay.
>> So, can you just tell the model that?
>> Yep. Yep. So, we're going to start.
Publishing and tracing timeouts do not
matter for this. So you can just ignore
them. Don't include that information in
the document
>> or more likely tell it explicitly they
don't matter. It's better. We we do want
to know that those timeouts exist, but
like
>> instead add a note that the publishing
and tracing timeouts don't matter, but
uh omit the kind of detailed
documentation about what it is. Um yep.
So we're going to launch that one and
then we're going to keep reading. So
this is how you kind of like can keep
keep the model working in the background
as you're continuing to review. So this
doc will update at some point as cloud
makes the changes but um well let's keep
going.
>> Publishing parsing
location property handler. Yep, this is
all correct. Uh time and options blah
blah blah. I believe that visit client.
Yep, that's all correct. Correct.
And just for everyone else, what am I
reading for when I read this code? I'm
actually not reading to like look for
perfect correctness. I'm looking for
approximate fuzzy matching because if
you know, if I was looking for perfect
correctness, I would actually jump to
that line in the codebase and then go
read it.
>> And you can do this if you're really
skeptical. One one advice I give also is
like you should probably
not try to make the research 100%
correct because there's diminishing
returns.
>> Exactly. So like I know what I'm looking
for is I'm like ah this file line is
roughly correct and that's good enough
for me.
>> So yeah line 45. This is Yep.
>> Okay. Request builder provider
implementation. Yep. That's where I call
request. It does the right thing. This
all correct. Go on.
>> Cool.
>> Composite client. No time out at
strategy level. Yep. That's a current
structure. That is correct.
>> Yes, that is correct. No deadline or
timeout. So we will need to go add that
in. And it's found it's found almost all
of them. It has missed orchestrator.rs.
So you probably want to tell it that
>> you missed orchestrator.rs.
Can you add notes about that one as
well?
>> And this is just like where me knowing
the codebase knows that if I don't say
this, it will get it wrong.
>> Um
>> in the which section is this?
>> Out. I don't think you have to tell it
that. It'll figure it out. Oh, sure. You
can say that, too.
>> I just I haven't read the whole thing
yet, so I don't know exactly. Um yeah.
Okay, cool. Cuz there might be Yeah.
Okay, cool. Uh, error handling
infrastructure.
>> Yeah, that's correct. Um,
that is correct.
>> Okay, made our change.
>> Mhm. Go on.
>> How the tests work.
>> I don't actually know if that's how the
test works, but I'm going to ignore that
for now.
>> Can you add inline code examples of uh
the test for each client SDK generation?
That is a bad bet. But sure, we can put
>> You don't think so?
>> Yeah, put it. Put it. It's fine.
>> We'll see how it works. We can always
roll it back.
>> Um, cool. Codegen pipeline. Is this
relevant?
>> No, but it's it probably is actually
because we do have to generate code. I
mean, not really. We don't really have
to generate code. So, maybe not.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. What's nice about this one is like
the timeouts is already implemented.
It's just not customizable. So, you know
that the flow is actually correct. like
the flow already works.
>> Well, kind of, but it's close. It's good
enough.
>> Yeah, it's a lot easier than the
cancellation one we did.
>> Yes.
>> Um, okay. And then this is code
references. This is just going to repeat
a lot of stuff about what was already
there.
>> Yeah. So, I just want to go read this
though, just so it knows um roughly what
it's doing.
>> So, here's your here's your test
simulation.
>> Nice. Okay. Can I read the test?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Let's go back up.
>> Show me the Python one first before I
read anything else.
>> Yeah,
>> a board controller with timeout MS.
>> So, this is just the test for the
cancellation stuff.
>> Yes. So, it did I mean you're
researching so it's not writing new code
probably.
>> Yeah.
>> Um
>> but this is probably actually not
relevant. I'm I was more looking for
like what unit tests are we going to
have to add to um test these new fields.
Yeah, that's you probably should have
phrased it that way.
>> Yeah. Yeah, that's actually wrong. Can
you remove those examples? I'm more
looking for what unit tests would we
have to add to test the new fields that
we want to add here? Um, so can you give
me just one example of uh how and where
there is a test um to test the actual
like BAML syntax? Um, and just one like
tight example and where it lives. Um,
this is going to be helpful for the
planning because we're going to want the
planning agent to Oops. Let's grab this.
Sometimes Super Whisper doesn't paste it
in. Um, cuz we're going to like we're
going to ask the planning agent to build
a test for us. So, um,
>> exactly. So, it'll go it'll go write
some stuff out. Um, that is correct
though where it does this. It's really
all in the property handler. There's
nothing else that has to be modified.
>> Okay.
>> Um,
yes. Uh Matt said something great which
is you should be using voice to prompt
uh for coding tasks. If you're not using
voice, you're just slowing yourself
down. Typing the reason and I'll I'll
give people an intuition about why this
is true because I it took me a little
bit to to come to the dark side. Um
which is or which is that when you're
typing, you almost want to think before
you type. And we're almost all
instinctively trained to do that. If you
make a typo, you're going to press
backspace and go write that out. when
you're speaking, you're going to speak a
lot more uh freely and you're just going
to inject more information in there,
which means that you the model will have
better context and the number of tokens
you inject even if you're speaking very
very verbosely is trivial compared to
the amount of context that you will
never get in there uh if you so just
like speak.
>> Yep. Amazing. Um cool. So yeah, we've
gotten it's updated our unit test
example with just this. So this is
integration test for client timeout
config.
>> Ah it got the spec wrong. Why doesn't
have HTTP in terms of the first one?
>> Yeah.
Uh yeah interesting.
>> Yeah I think it thinks it's optional.
>> Why doesn't the first one have the HTTP
nesting? That's incorrect. You need to
reread the spec and then update the unit
test. We're also getting a little high
on I try to keep the context under 40%.
That's when you get 40 to 50 range. If
it's easy and we're almost there, I will
usually keep it. Um, but you always want
to be pretty aggressive about the
context. But I think I'm ready to start
uh doing the plan for this one
>> once almost. I trust me that we should
just make sure it's actually good
>> because otherwise it's going to be a
waste of time.
>> Yep.
>> Um, we should add some caveats in here
that I think are not obvious. Um, and I
think the spec is actually
underspecified. Idle timeout is only
relevant if called during a stream. Time
to first token is only relevant if
called during a stream.
>> Worth noting um idle timeout is only
relevant if called during a stream and
time to first token timeout is also only
relevant if called during a stream. Can
you update the specification with that
note, not the research?
>> And specifically what you want to add in
is orchestrator/call.rs
does not care about it and orchestrator.
RS does care about it. And this is kind
of that nuance of why I know u this is
this is just me knowing the codebase
like times the first token is a feature
that is only relevant if you're calling
it with stream like function b.stream.f
function name instead of b.f function
name
>> and and this is why we say is like this
is this is real engineering like the
people other people who say like work a
lot with coding agents is the the idea
that like the best engineers have the
entire codebase downloaded into their
brain or whatever you want to call it
like that is still super valuable. the
same way it's valuable if you're
navigating in an IDE and and writing
code by hand.
>> Yeah. Cool. Let's go read let's go read
this now from the top down so then we
can like make sure that we actually
understood it. And you probably need to
refresh, right?
>> Yep. And we're refreshed.
>> Okay. Perfect. Okay.
>> So here's our mod. RS special client
handling
note on the tracing timeouts. Perfect.
>> Um
>> that's just where the data is. It's in
property val
>> property parsing. Yep.
parser database provider for specific
parsing athropic vertex composite
clients. No time out. No time out.
>> Can you scroll up? I want to read the
composite clients uh carefully.
>> Yep.
>> Yep. Okay. Go down. Okay, that's good. I
read that.
>> This is the interesting part. Yeah.
>> Would need total timeout implementation
only. Correct. Um
yes, I think that is correct. Line 221.
Um, it may not be in stream.rs. That's
probably the easiest place to put it
actually. Can we just open that file and
look at it?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> And this is kind of where it starts to
be like really relevant because like if
I were trying to do this myself, I would
have to think really really hard.
>> Yeah. And when we say like, hey, we
don't we don't edit files and cursor,
you still probably will end up reading
quite a bit of code. God, why? Who did
this?
Why is uh Oh, sorry. We need stream. RS
>> down. Yeah. And what line number?
>> There we go.
>> 21.
>> Um, go down. Okay, I'm good. This looks
correct.
>> You're happy with this is where you
would want that stuff implemented,
right?
>> This is where I would want this
implemented. So, I agree.
>> Yeah. So, this really serves not only as
like documentation, but also like very
subtle steering to where you want your
changes implemented.
>> Yeah. And can you go up really fast?
>> This is where total idle timeout would
be and where um time to first token. And
it's really interesting that this doc
captures all that because like now I'm
like, "Okay, cool. I feel confident that
whatever thing is going to work on this,
we'll have some context that is really,
really relevant."
>> Yep. And just as a fun exercise, I'm
going to go kick off the plan now.
>> Yeah. Yeah. One other 16:30.
>> Yep. Read the spec in spec.md
and the research. Um, actually, I'm
going to show you a cool trick. I'm just
going to run create plan because if you
run it with no arguments, it will um
just ask you what do you want to plan?
>> But isn't that extra context?
>> Extra context, but it's also the right
trajectory. So the planning prompt
actually is like a threephase back and
forth with the user. And sometimes if
you just run create plan and tell it
what to do, it kind of there's a chance
that it skips those interactive steps.
And so by doing by doing create plan and
then this back and forth, hold on, this
is a really important concept. By doing
create plan and then having it answer me
and then I say the next thing, you're
setting the trajectory to be a little
bit more towards your fot prompting the
model that it's often like checking back
with the user and that this is a back
and forth, not a just go call tools
until the thing is solved. You I'll I'll
show you what this means.
>> I I believe you. But for for this
personally, I would just run it cuz I'm
just lazy. Like I'm not I'm not this
would feel like a micro optimization for
myself, but I might be wrong.
>> Uh if you work with these prompts a bit,
you will you will you will uh you will
agree with me.
>> Um where is this thing? You got too many
files in your repo. You're breaking my
uh fuzzy finder.
>> Bro, I have a big code base.
>> Yeah, once I kick this off, we're also
going to run clock. We're going to do
this. Let's work back and forth to uh
outline the phases. Start with your open
questions for me and then give me a
phase outline before writing the plan.
We're just going to give it as much
extra steering as possible to um
>> for this problem. Given how detailed the
research was, I would have actually just
let it rip.
>> Uh you can, but I'm also like want to
kind of show more generally, right?
We're not just solving the problem.
We're But like that's fair. So the
research prompt is actually going to go
do some of its the plan prompt is going
to go do some of its own research. Say
what?
>> You want to auto approve everything?
>> Oh yeah. I'm also going to kick off a
clock which is uh count lines of code
just just for audience context on how
much code is in this codebase.
>> That's a I don't know man.
>> You don't want to see it. Let's see.
Script 200,000 Rust 200,000. Go 130,000.
This is more than last time, dude. This
is crazy.
>> Yeah.
Yeah. I know a lot of this is generated
though.
>> Can you ignore intact test when you run
this? Just ignore the int test folder or
go into Yeah, if there's a way to ignore
ignore BML client basically. Uh BML
client. Yeah, just enter if it'll finds
that. It's like BML client anywhere in
the path.
Oh,
>> we'll do this later.
>> Oh, you need to use Do you not use warp?
>> No, I don't use warp. I use cloud.
>> Interesting.
ignoring also uh star. Uh oh yeah, maybe
that'll work. That'll probably do
something
interesting. I just use warp and I found
it to be pretty good for this stuff.
Works pretty good if you want to just do
it on the CLI. Um I just do everything
in here now. So this thing is
researching again like even though the
research is pretty succinct, um the
planning planning code is designed to do
a little bit of research up front as
well. This is also so that if your
problem is really simple, you can go
straight to planning and you don't have
to do the full research, especially if
you have a smaller codebase. You can
just do the plan and get get better
results.
>> What do we get in clock while it's
running?
>> Let's see.
>> Let's see what we got. There we go. That
looks more appropriate.
>> Okay. Yeah, now it's all rust. And do
you have decode in there? What is that?
>> I don't know what decode. It's reading
something as decode. That's probably
just like config files we have.
>> I mean, clock is a old janky tool. So um
>> yeah this looks about right. Okay cool.
>> Um okay cool. So open questions. Timeout
interaction hierarchy when multiple
timeout mechanisms are active user
configured abort signal retry policy.
What's the priority order?
>> Um what wait
>> should an abort signal immediately
cancel regardless of timeout settings?
>> Yes. Abort should immediately cancel.
>> Should retry attempts each get a fresh
timeout duration?
>> Yes. attempts should each get a fresh
timeout set duration. Cool.
Um it's like as the spec suggests. So
it's like it's gonna it's gonna always
try to come up with some open questions.
Um some of them are just like softballs
of like you want me to do what it said
in the spec. Um should it trigger
between any SSE events including PE keep
alive pings or is it only chunks?
>> Um
only chunks.
>> Only chunks.
Keep alive do not reset the timer. Okay.
Question three.
HTB block structure. Yes. Enforce the
structure not allowed at the top left.
Composite climate should only accept
total timeout.
>> Dude, you got to switch to whisper
floats. A lot more accurate.
>> I just downloaded the biggest model on
Super Whisper to test with it. But
um default timeout values. I'm also
going to have to go get a charger in a
sec.
>> Should we maintain the current
hard-coded defaults? 10-second connect,
30 second read as fallbacks when no
configuration provider.
>> Yes, keep the default.
>> Yes.
>> Five. Error information granularity.
Yeah. How do you want to display errors
to the user?
>> That was underspecified. Um,
tracked elapse time.
Uh,
just BAML timeout error uh with uh no
data for now. Oh
yeah, it should it should be a subset of
uh BMA client error. Uh it should be a
it should be a child of BMA client error
subclass subclass subasses
>> was environment
>> silent degrade if unsupported.
>> Okay. And then let's look at the phases.
So phase one, and when we're designing
phases, what I really like to do is um
really focus on what is the
incrementably testable thing. I don't
know if that's actually going to be
relevant since you have such good unit
integration test coverage, but if you're
building like a full stack application,
I kind of like if I'm not going to
actually be able to look at it and
verify it until the end of phase three,
I'll just have it combine all three of
those into one phase. Um, there's some
art and science to this, but what do you
think about this?
>> Excuse me. Um, let me take a look and
think about this more.
>> I think this is uh yeah, that's probably
a good phase one.
>> So, we we're skipping the streaming
stuff. We're just doing the the the core
client and basic time.
>> It's really just like parsing clients is
what I would describe that as.
>> Yeah.
>> As like parsing stuff.
>> Yep. Then we add in the BAML timeout
error. Yeah, that makes sense.
>> Create those errors in the SDKs.
>> Yeah.
>> Yep.
>> Then do this. I would probably move
phase 4 right with phase one personally.
>> Okay.
For phases, let's do phase 4 right after
phase.
>> No, right with right as a part of phase
one.
>> Phase one.
>> Yeah. Uh because it's the same parsing.
You can even tell that since it's the
same parsing logic. since it's the same
parsing logic file.
Um, okay. Phase five, testing and
documentation.
Don't do tests at the end. Add tests as
>> No, no, don't do that. Don't do that.
Don't do that. Don't do No,
>> really.
>> Leave that for now. The code base is
[__] So, that's not how I would tell
it.
>> I'll tell you.
>> What do you want to do? You want to just
leave this as like we'll write the test
at the end?
>> Just back backspace all that so far and
just run all the commands you have so
far. Give me like one second to think
about how to tell it that.
>> Okay, I'm gonna hit this. I'm gonna go
grab a charger. Um
and then
>> Yeah, let I'm not gonna hit
>> let it create the plan. Hit enter, let
it create the plan, and then we'll come
back to that testing thing in a second.
>> Yeah. And then we'll read the created
plan and we can iterate from there.
>> Yeah, exactly. Cuz I want to read the
actual plan. Um and then I think I'm
good. Uh but you should fire it off to
let it run the plan.
>> So for context for everyone else, what
have we done so far? In about an hour,
we've gone through where we had this
spec that we wrote that like roughly
outlines new syntax that we have. We
took that spec, we asked an LLM to go
modify it to some more updates. We then
told the LM to go research the BAML
codebase to go and understand exactly
what the codebase is doing and like what
parts are relevant to make that change.
And by the end of this hour, we now have
even an implementation plan of like
here's how we would go implement this by
step by step. And hopefully in the next
10 to 15 minutes, we'll have the full
implementation plan ready to go. And
once we have the implementation plan,
the rest of this is actually really,
really, really fast because once a plan
is approved, letting a model rip and run
is so fast.
But the key part is having really,
really good documentation there. For
example, if you go back and look at this
earlier, some of you may have seen that
uh one of the things that we did was we
added streaming as an early part of the
stream to the actual spec. And because
the research did not pick that out as
unique,
>> that was an important
>> super high leverage. And this is again
this was the whole point of like a bad
line of code is a bad line of code. A
bad part of a plan is a is a is a 100
bad lines of code. And a like
misunderstanding of which parts of the
system are relevant can tank your entire
project.
>> Exactly. So like because we knew that
that information is relevant, we added
that in and that was actually why the
model realized that hey idle idle time
is only relevant during streaming and so
and that's what I realized too while
doing that. Idle time is only relevant
during streaming and like time to first
token is only relevant during streaming.
We don't want to like error out in the
normal in the normal call pattern when
you're not streaming for time to first
token. Um so while this is almost done,
it's going to go and implement all this
stuff and it's going to write the plan
and then we'll go read the detail plan.
Dextra, while we do this, I want to
>> go download Obsidian.
>> I want to make you download this.
>> Yeah, I actually would love to see your
Obsidian workflow.
>> Just You can't homebrew it. Just
download it.
>> Yes, I can.
>> Oh, maybe you can,
>> bro. You can homebrew anything, man.
>> Okay. Yeah, cuz you've been talking a
lot about how you use this. And actually
one thing I think that is interesting
that is like a thing that I find when I
work with people on these kind of
projects is like and what works when
we're sitting together is like I think
instead of me listening to you and then
translating it into feedback, I can just
hand you the mic and you can talk at the
model. And that's that's like a thing
where it's like when there's two people
working, it's really helpful to be able
to switch back and forth between who's
prompting quickly. And we don't have
that today cuz we're live on a stream
and we're not doing a screen share or
whatever it is, but like being able to
This is running. Can you hold Super
Whisper and I'll talk and we'll just see
if it pulls it up and listen.
>> I don't think it can pull my computer
audio.
>> Wait, are you you have uh Wait, do you
have uh headphones on?
>> If you take off your headphones, it will
listen to me and it'll plug it in.
>> All right, let's try it.
>> Let's see if this works virtually.
>> All right, let's go.
>> Okay, so we can do that. Uh I'm going to
go back to headphones just for the audio
quality, but that's good to know. Um the
the point I was making about like
obsidian and stuff is basically
uh this creates one of the workflows
that you may want that is helpful for um
collaborating with your team, right?
Because like what makes this workflow
really shine is the um open folder.
>> Just open a folder as a vault. Yeah.
Plans and put in reader view. So why do
I why do I personally like this work?
Can you zoom in a bit more?
>> Yep.
Why do I personally like this workflow
where using bare markdown files? Well,
one is I can switch between reader mode
and writer mode. Two, you saw earlier,
one of the things that we were doing is
we were actually asking the model to go
make every edit. Some edits are just
easier to make manually and not have to
go back and forth between the model. And
two, I find reading this to just be
prettier.
>> It's just for me personally, I find this
view to be much much better.
>> Okay,
>> I like it.
>> So, desired ends. This is our this is
our like concise spec. Let's read the
first first few lines. And I apologize
to everyone on the stream that's
watching me and Dexter read a bunch of
stuff. Um,
sadly, this is just what we have to do.
>> This is worth it, too. Like, this is the
part you want to be doing and spending
time on. I I talked to a lot of people
who are uh they get to this and they're
like, "Okay, cool. So, like we can use
the model to write the plans and we can
use the model to write the research.
Like, what if we had the model write the
specs, too, and we can the model write a
really good spec?" And it's like, the
plan gives you 10x leverage. The
research gives you a 100x leverage.
Times you just have to learn to be happy
with being a 100x faster and not try to
get to a thousand because then it things
become hard in a weird way. And there's
sometimes the things that you want to do
manually whether it's reading or
manually pruning these specs that is
still worth doing even though like
you've been told that like if if you if
you're doing something AI should be able
to do it. There's like a there's like a
top out where it's like diminishing
returns. Does that make sense by does
that track?
>> That's right.
>> Yep. Um, so let's go on. This looks
correct. You're right. The um, as the
model will say, you're absolutely
correct.
>> Yeah, we don't say we don't say that
other thing here on stream.
>> Okay, that looks correct. Let's go down.
Fall back and only support this.
>> We're not doing go down.
Um,
>> be an HTTP block. Not adding detailed
metadata to the error objects yet.
>> Yes. Not impossing time out in any WASM
environments.
Not changing default time up behavior.
One second. Not implementing complex
timeout inheritance between composite
and underlying clients.
>> Great.
>> Yes. We're not inheriting time. Every
client is independent.
>> Yep.
>> Implementation approach. H. Okay. Cool.
>> Um, cool. Okay. So, phase one, we are
going to update the helpers to add the
HTTP block.
>> Can you go up? I want to read this a
little bit better. And for context for
everyone else, it's like what are we
doing here? Well, we're going to read
the code. We're notice normally you
don't read all the AI generated code.
I'm going to read this code because this
is relevant. So, I will spend time
reading this
>> and and this is like
the idea is that this is higher leverage
than actually reading the code the model
wrote because it's more of an outline.
Like this is actually not going to
include every single line of code, but
it's going to be the directionally like
like important parts and it's going to
be line by line.
>> We don't have good errors here. So, we
should give the tell the model that you
didn't add good errors for this phase of
the plan.
>> Go down. I don't think it did. I'll just
let's just read the plan a little bit
better.
>> Yeah, let's let's finish reading phase
one and then we'll we'll give it our
feedback.
>> Ignore for now. Okay. Okay, that's fine.
It has some bail is bad. We really want
errors. I think we do want an error
actually because I mean that was the
other issue we fixed is like someone had
they misspelled this and they didn't get
an error.
>> Yeah, exactly. So tell it that we want
good errors here.
>> We want good errors for unrecognized
fields in the HTTP block because the
user needs feedback to know that they
have typed something wrong or
unsupported.
>> Enter. While that runs, we can keep
going.
>> Yep.
>> This is so fun. I love I love this [__]
>> Let's go on.
Okay, that's perfect. Um,
>> so this is the config.
>> Okay, cool. This part I have no idea
what it does. So to be honest, I'm like
whatever. This is going to figure.
>> So we're going to use the users config
and then we're going to map it from
milliseconds and then we're going to
unwrap it or use the default.
>> We should probably have a way to define
infinite infinite in some way. That's
underspecified in this doc.
>> Um, what is infinite? Minus one.
>> Yeah.
>> Whoops. Let's go. Uh, no. Let's use zero
for infinite.
>> If a user puts zero as the timeout, that
should mean infinite timeout and
override the default.
>> Oh, why zero as a timeout?
>> I upgraded to the super ultra model from
Super Whisper and it's not very good.
>> And I don't know if zero is the right
thing, but like we can use zero for now.
Um, we could also make the user write
in, but that's okay. Let's just do this
for now.
>> Okay, cool. I'm going to just stash that
because it's still working and I don't
want to interrupt it.
Um okay, cool. So now we have um
>> I believe the errors here are fine.
>> Okay.
>> Um uh
>> unrecognized fields not as empty bail.
>> Wait, go up. What did it say about
providers?
>> Go up. It said something about providers
>> is composite fallback or round robin. Is
there any other providers?
>> Round-roin.
Okay.
In the provider check block, it's round
dashroin.
>> There you go.
>> Um, and we're almost getting to 40%. So,
I depending on where we're at after this
round of feedback, I will probably start
a new context window and just be like,
"Hey, we're working on this plan."
>> Cool. We'll figure out the error
checking here. I think the error
checking can be much better. So, we'll
deal with that later.
>> Yep.
>> Yeah. This is going to change, but um
Okay.
>> Cool. It's cool that the model inferred
that zero is a error.
>> It's an infinite. Oh,
>> it did.
>> Yeah. Zero. Oh, this just changed after
I put the feedback in.
>> Oh,
>> do you want to have a 10-minute max?
>> You can just delete that. Just delete
that. And this is what I mean. Like this
is like where we don't have to think
about this. Maybe. Yeah.
Yeah. I don't want to put a max on
there. Screw it. Who knows how good
models get. Maybe we do have 10-minute
long HTB requests that we run.
Do you want to leave this in? This is
validator. Like I think this is the only
one.
>> Um, no. What What does the other one do?
>> It's literally This is just validating
the timeout. So it's like these mean the
same thing.
Okay,
cool. Um, all right. Let's get to the
end of phase one and then we can
actually Well, let's keep going. Does
this look right?
>> Yeah, this looks about right. This is
just passing it through to the HTTP
client.
>> Makes sense. One thing I don't like
about this. Can you go up?
>> Yeah. Yep.
>> I don't like that this stuff is done
over here. I feel like this stuff should
actually be done in the constructor. So
like the defaults should actually be
configured in the parsing
like for all these timeouts we have the
defaults right there.
>> So we should just like the default
should be con in as a part of the
previous section, not as part of this
section.
>> So that way we don't have to reduplicate
the defaults like in five places.
>> Okay. So basically the default should
happen in in this section, not the other
one.
>> Uh yeah.
>> Yeah. Okay. So now we're at 63%. So I'm
going to make a new one.
>> Oh.
>> No, we're going to make a new one.
Sorry, bud.
>> Okay.
>> We're not creating a new plan. We're
updating an existing plan. I'll give you
the path below. Um so don't need to kick
off any research to start. Just use the
guidelines to update the plan. I'm going
to give you the path and some feedback
below. You need better fuzzy match.
>> I know something's going on.
>> You can just right click. You can right
click on that one. The one above. Just
right click on the right click on the
file on Obsidian and it'll give it to
you.
>> Okay. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Copy. Copy path.
>> Yeah.
>> Copy.
>> There we go.
>> You need to put thoughts in front of it.
>> Yeah.
>> I would actually let it read the plan
and then give it feedback after.
>> Yeah.
>> Cuz then that's going to become like
>> in phase one part three, we configured
the defaults. I'd like to instead uh set
up the defaults in part two where we
create the client. Is that is that
right?
>> Yeah.
Or where I parse the client in part one
I think where I parse the PL client.
Yeah. There you go.
>> Cool. Let's keep on going. Can you make
it wider again?
>> Yep.
>> Yeah.
>> This stuff looks really good. It's
actually really simple because it seems
like so straightforward in terms of how
it would implement it. That's fantastic.
>> Um okay, so zero. No timeout, none, use
the default. We're going to move the
default up, but
>> yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. So then we'll always have it. And
if it says none and zero should really
be none, I think this will do the right
thing. Zero and none should behave the
same.
>> Are you sure? Isn't none use the default
timeout, but zero is explicitly set?
>> No, because it'll be set now in the
other code. Uh yeah, there you go. See,
it changed it automatically to reflect
that behavior.
>> Perfect.
>> This is a lot easier to think about.
Cool. Do you want to skim the change it
made or you trust it?
>> Yeah, I do want to skim the change it
made.
Um, ensure uh I don't like this
happening here. This should happen as a
part of HTTP config. Like as a part of
insure http config.
>> This should happen as a part of ensure
HTTP config. Oops.
>> Uh, so it actually
>> what happened? Yeah.
>> So it'll do the defaults there.
>> Okay, cool.
>> And once it's done, I hate that you're
absolutely right. It's so frustrating to
see.
>> Yeah.
>> Um Okay.
>> It's frustrating to see this early in a
context window.
>> It's fine.
>> Um Okay.
>> And then composite client total timeout.
>> Make it wider again.
>> Yep.
>> Okay. Let's keep reading.
>> Let's Well, it just made a change. Let's
go check the change.
>> What? Why didn't it make the change in
the right place?
Go up.
Okay. So, it did do this here.
If it's not a composite, it adds some
default in there. That's good. That is
correct.
>> Um, it also rolled. I don't know. I
edited this in Obsidian. I don't know if
it actually saved.
>> It does save. You just have to hit
command S, but that's fine.
>> Just going to remove this stuff.
>> Yeah, you're done.
>> Since I don't trust it.
>> Um,
you can go confirm. Just less than zero.
>> This is the research. That's why. Okay,
good. Yeah, cool. Command S works. Yeah.
>> Okay. This looks good.
This looks good.
>> Wait, can you
>> Why is it doing this twice?
>> That's fine.
>> Connect timeout. Request timeout. Okay.
The two different timeouts.
>> Composite time. Total timeout. That's
fine. Does this work? Can I see this one
more time?
>> Yep.
>> Yeah. Orchestrate.
>> I want to look at how orchestrate works.
Total timeout. Okay. Yep.
Yeah, that's correct.
>> Board signal is already there. Existing
retry logic with fresh timeout per
attempt.
>> Yep, that's correct. Okay,
>> that's good.
Does this need to be a special error or
is this right?
>> That probably should be a special error,
but I think that's okay because we
haven't implemented the error yet.
>> Yeah. Okay. And then for streaming,
we're going to do basically the same
thing. So, this is the like compaction
part, right? We're not writing every
single line of code, but it's like,
okay, we did this and this is going to
be about the same.
Yeah, I think the only difference is we
should use Tokyo Select here, but that's
a separate problem. I'll deal with that
later.
>> Are you sure you don't want to change
that?
>> Yeah, you should tell it that. You
should tell it code later. Like we
should use Let's use Tokyo Select. It'll
it'll know what I want.
>> Probably should have told it phase one,
but okay.
>> Figured out.
>> There are examples for user feedback.
>> Yeah. Can you make it read only view
again?
>> Yeah. Connect timeout. Yeah, that's
>> unrecognized fields. supported timeout
fields
not allowed for composite
composite clients only support connect
must be non- negative zero valid means
no timeout yeah these are all our like
test cases basically
>> yeah um and you should I think there's
something in the doc that's somehow
telling it that uh there's yeah there
you go you got that right
>> the select stuff this is right
>> yeah it looks more correct than before
>> here we go okay cool um cool
>> okay um That phase looks correct.
>> Uh that is not the right that is we
don't have make files.
>> Yeah, that's actually I have a global
clot ND that steers it to make and I'm
going to have to get rid of that.
>> Um those are the wrong testing commands
at the end of phase one. Um what should
I tell it to?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> I'm also like I'm a little bit worried
this isn't actually telling it to add
unit tests.
>> Um
there are no unit tests here, but that's
okay. Uh well I I'll talk about testing
in a second with BAML.
>> Okay, cool.
>> Um I would probably say is it's it's
kind of meaty for phase one. It should
really just get all the configs right.
That's what I would call all of phase
one. All of phase one is just
configs right. And and
>> so what do you want to take out?
>> I would just split out phase one to the
parsing and actually adding the timeouts
as phase two.
>> Cool. Yeah, this is like a thing in
phase design, right? is you want to it's
like it's how how would you build this
right? How would how much code would you
write before you pause to like run
something?
>> Yeah. And the reason by the way I say
this is because I know that we can add
tests at at the parsing layer first
before we add tests for the rest of it.
>> And I might honestly just say like
everything cargo test passes.
>> Uh I'll tell I'll give you specific
tests to run actually after this.
>> Um or the model can do it.
>> Yeah, I know. But I I'll tell you what
to run and then you can just tell it
that it's not actually cargo test. We'll
have to if you edit this here, it's
going to edit it again. You're going to
get screwed. So you can't you can't
multi hop.
>> Yep. Okay,
>> cool. Let's keep reading though. Um
because even if it renames the phases,
that's fine.
>> Yep. Okay. Um error handling
enhancement.
>> Yep. This is correct.
>> Python SDK error. TypeScript SDK error.
Go SDK error.
>> Cool. Looks good.
>> Well, Go SDK doesn't have errors yet.
>> Oh, really? Pretty sure that doesn't
exist. I'm like 85% sure that that does
not exist.
>> Just want to see what is it doing here.
>> While we're doing this um and while Dex
is running this question, feel free to
keep firing them off while this is
executing because like we have a lot of
downtime while this runs.
>> Yeah. And this is why actually I think
pair programming is really good for this
kind of work because there is a little
bit of downtime. And if you're doing it
solo, I would just go check Twitter or
something. But when you're sitting with
another engineer building stuff, you can
actually take the downtime to like
engage on the problem, think about
what's next, talk about some of the
things that we haven't figured out yet.
Do we have more questions?
>> Keep on going. I'll let them know what's
the questions coming. I'm watching the
chat.
>> Cool. Thanks.
>> Okay, so phase one is parsing and
validation.
>> This is insure HTTP config. And then
phase two should be. And so
>> now what I want to cargo test is not
enough. Now what I'll tell you is I'll
actually show you how to add tests. The
way that you add test is you go into our
repo. Open our repo really fast just so
you know what I'm pointing to in cursor.
>> Yep.
>> Open that and then go to engine
slashablam
test. Yeah. and then do command B so I
can see the sidebar and then uh scroll
up uh it may not it's in validation
files.
>> Oh here we go.
>> So this is where new thing in client
open client and we like boom be like hey
add new tests to this file. These are
all incorrect but there's a mechanism to
run them. Copy path.
Yep. And just tell it to add test for
phase one. You can add test to this
file. Yeah. And then the way that you
run them is cargo test from within that
within um no no not to the whole patch
just engine baml libbaml.
>> So yeah one thing I will say is um this
is the kind of thing that you're not
going to want to tell it manually for
every plan. And so this is the kind of
thing where you could go update your
create plan command to say to give a
guidance around how the tests work for
different parts of the codebase. We're
not going to do that today but that's
like room for improvement. Specifically
what you want to tell the system is this
is how you run parser tests like uh
th this is how you run like parsing
tests or like a validation test.
read a few other files in there to get a
sense how it works
>> and also tell it that the comments
automatically get updated um with the
comments automatically get updated
the er the error comments
if when you run
update_exect equals 1 all caps uh cargo
test dot dot dot Yeah, there you go. So
like that's just like a mechanism that
we have. Yeah, cool. That's it. Tell
that now it should be able now it should
be able to go good test. That's why I
didn't want to do testing stuff earlier
because I wanted to have some context
here. I was like there's just no way
that we'll get this right in that part
of the
>> Well, you want you want to kind of read
the plan and you know what it already
knows and that gives it enough context
to actually go put in the right unit
test.
>> Exactly.
>> Cool.
>> And rep are we using obsidian as a
knowledge base or just as temp for
creating your prompts or context? I
actually I personally never save my
prompts and my repo my research and
plans in my codebase permanently. It's
like a separate artifact that lives
independent of it. And Obsidian is just
a really good markdown viewer and
reader. So that's what I read.
>> Yeah. And also like I think we found a
lot is like we in the past have like
kept all historical research and plans
and given the model access to like
review them for historical context. And
what I'm finding more and more is like
you almost never want that. And so what
you want is you want the model to have
access to all of the research and plans
and specs for a specific project. And I
say project, I mean like this issue that
we're solving and then when you move on
to another project, all that stuff is
becomes not by default visible. Um
unless you ask the model to like go
search for specific things. We do have a
couple files that I call like golden
research which are just like the model
should probably always be able to find
this stuff because it's like here's how
the tests work. like this kind of
information could get put into a
research file that is always available
to the model, but you'd want it to like
be kind of like hand hand manicured and
really really cuz that's a high leverage
thing.
>> Can I read the plan?
>> Yeah, let's see what it did.
>> Okay, cool.
>> Yep.
>> Add validation test. Okay, go on. So, go
down. So, it just shows you error
examples, but then it actually starts
adding validation tests. That's great.
That's great. That's great. That's
great.
And then it will tell you how to go do
this in it. Now tells you invalid tests,
what are happening. Cool. That's fine.
Like all these errors and stuff are
totally fine.
>> Cool.
>> Adds a bunch of tests and then it should
make them pass and some of them won't
pass. So then it'll just like run the
diff themselves.
>> Messages.
>> Uh let's I would actually run phase one.
I would just let let it run phase one.
>> Cool. And then we'll go back and fix the
rest of the plan once we know what's up.
>> Exactly. So while while we're waiting
and reading the rest of it, I would let
it run on phase one.
>> So will you would you actually run every
single one of these commands?
>> Yes, that is how I would run this.
>> Um,
>> yes, that is correct.
>> Make sure this passes. So it's it's it
does have the same thing.
>> I I would get rid of I would I would get
rid of default. Defaults are applied for
non-composite clients. Yes. Um,
>> yeah, I would get rid of that. Yeah,
we're just testing the parser stuff.
>> Yep, there we go. That's all fine. You
can leave that there.
>> It'll probably only run it once.
>> Yeah, it'll figure it out.
>> And then we're just going to not do
manual verification here, right? H
>> It's fine. Let let it be there. I would
let it run. And I would just let it run
on um And the only reason I'm I'm um the
I would just tell it to only run phase
one. I And you're going to start.
>> I will. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But I also put
that in there just to over steer it a
little bit.
>> Create plan.
>> Um, cool.
>> Yeah. Implement. Yep. And just let it
rip. And now let's go back to reading
the plan while this is running.
>> And this is something that I I have
often done because we've already read
phase one and we kind of split it into
two separate plans. I'm okay letting
this happen. I I am not at all worried
about like it messing up at this phase.
So I will let it go do that and it'll
make some progress and at some point the
code will be done. Probably in a couple
minutes to be honest. Cool. So, I'm
going to kick off since this one was
getting fairly high. I'm just going to
close this one out and I'm going to use
the same prompt. I literally copied the
same prompt, which is like create plan,
read the file, and then wait for my
feedback.
>> Cool. Let's keep on reading.
>> Cool. Timeout implementation. So, this
is the stuff we moved out of phase one.
>> Yep. So, it's now actually going to
create the client. So, this is this is
much better than before.
>> Yep.
>> Cool. And then this is our applying the
actual timeout to the sync stuff
>> in the each client. And then the
composite client total.
>> Um we have our Tokyo pin. We have our
Tokyo select. So I think this all looks
right. I don't
>> error is out there. I agree with this. I
think we should move the error
definitions up before this happens. Like
we should expose error will need to be
implemented and it's not done yet. So
like
>> in phase two, let's move the exposed
error up and implement it before the
>> I would just move error definitions
before I would just move error. I would
delete that and let's tell it to move
move the phase of defining errors before
we actually do uh the request
definition.
>> So in phase two, let's just define all
the errors first before we go in and do
the request definition stuff.
>> Then let's split out the phases. It
might that might interpret it as do it
in phase two.
>> Do you want to do it instead of phase
two? I want to do it in Yeah, I want to
do it before phase two. Like I want
phase two to move down one more step.
>> Make that into phase three and then add
a phase 2 that is just define all the
errors first.
>> Cool.
>> Exactly.
>> And again, it's all about breaking down
the problem into smaller and smaller
components that are all going to
individually compile because like this
is a huge compilation task. So my whole
goal is compile as much as possible
ahead of time. And one of the benefits,
for example, of using Rust is if it
compiles, it probably works.
>> Rust.
>> This somehow got our stupid value
greater than 10 minutes
>> cuz there's a line somewhere in there
that says like look up 10 minutes. I bet
you there's a thing in there in one of
the things that says like 10-minute max.
>> It just rewrote this again. I tried to
edit it.
>> Yeah, but go look up in the other Go
look up in the other one.
Go look up in the research.
>> Didn't read the research though.
>> It did.
Not in the imp. This is the implementer.
This is the thing actually going to like
do the code.
>> What file calls did it make?
>> It read the plan. My point is like the
plan we we edited that plan to remove it
and it got put back in. So
>> this is why I don't this is why this is
why I don't manually edit sometimes
because the model will just keep
rewriting it with the new stuff.
>> I think I have a separate prompt that I
use that tells it that sometimes I make
edits that you don't have.
>> I see.
>> Um it's fine if it has that. We can just
remember that. Like honestly, a
10-minute max is fine.
>> No, we're going to fix this.
>> Oh, it actually completed phase
implement. Well, this Are you? No, the
implement plan doesn't need it.
>> I want to update the plan cuz every
every model from here on out is going to
see that in the plan, and it's going to
be like, oh, that's wrong. I'm going to
go fix that, too.
>> Yeah, but then then we should be an
implement plan. We should do this in
create plan. Fire it off. Okay, let's
keep on reading it. Did
>> Hold on. Hold on. No, because I want to
make sure that the actual implementer
also has that. Updated the plan for
validation to simplify the logic. Read
the file again and update the
validation. I'm just going to stage
that. I'm not going to send it.
>> All right. Cool.
Um,
cool. Let me go read this really fast.
Let me read the plan while it's working.
>> Yep.
>> Um, we just want I want to read the next
phase because this part is done. Phase
one should be done. Cool. Error type
definition.
>> Cool. That was correct. Correct. Go up.
No, you're going too fast. My brain
doesn't read that fast.
>> And I do want to read everything else.
>> Yep.
>> Yes. Damn. Time out error. It comes from
a client. So, we actually have all the
client metadata for free. Yes.
>> Yep. Correct.
>> You said this doesn't exist yet.
>> I'm pretty sure. I mean, just go check
that file. Yeah, it's I don't see it.
>> Cool. That's what I thought. Um, so Go
doesn't have errors. Just like delete.
>> Should we just skip this?
>> Just delete it. Delete. Delete it and
just say like doesn't have errors. And
you can tell if you want.
>> The Go SDK doesn't have support for
errors. So remove step four from that
phase entirely. We'll just skip that for
now.
>> And same with Ruby.
>> Same with Ruby. Same with Ruby.
>> Technically, we do have errors. I just
don't want to deal with it right now.
Uh,
and you should say focus only in Python.
Oh, whatever. It's fine.
That's good enough. Let's go back and
read.
>> Okay,
>> this thing is still implementing.
It's doing its thing. And a large part
of actually using AI models is really
about just like moving fast and
paralyzing. So that's why we're
implementing phase one without having to
go through all of it.
>> It's just not worth the time.
>> So now we just have Python and
Typescript. And here's the mapping. And
that's the end of the phase. Is this
right? Like string contains timeout.
>> No, we will eis connect. I don't know
what that E is. Can you go to that file?
Just like look up what that file reads
like. I have no idea. And again, this is
just another benefit of having like the
actual file references. Like we can just
like read this stuff. Just go back and
read. Um, no, it's somewhere down below
>> line in execute request or error
handling. So here we look at the status.
No, this won't be in here. This is
incorrect. This will only ever be in the
I don't know where the error will come.
I mean, maybe where's execute request
match.
>> So, what here's a good example of like
um
>> I have no idea what Russ does here to
actually see where it happens.
>> Like,
>> so this is
>> this is what I'm going to do. I'm going
to show you a cool trick that shouldn't
happen here. Use codebase pattern finder
to see how errors from HTTP clients are
handled.
>> I'm pretty sure it does happen there, by
the way. Oh,
anyway, that's fine.
>> Okay. Uh, close enough. We'll figure it
out.
>> It's somewhere in there. Um, is the
other one done yet?
>> The implement.
>> Why is it running make? It's running
make.
>> It's my global cloud MD. Read the damn
plan, you nerd.
>> Cool. And then I think what what should
end up happening here is once phase one
is done, then we should be able to get
phase two to compile. Once phase two
compiles, then we can actually go
implement it.
>> Yeah.
Um
I'm actually going to stop this cuz the
context's getting quite high.
>> It should be fine. Trust me, I've run it
to like 80% for these guys, especially
during the last part of running tests.
>> But we also have to update this all this
logic. All the unit tests are wrong
because we updated the plan to remove
that timeout max. So, like we have to
fix that and then we have to get the
test passing.
>> It will matter because it's going to fix
and get all the tests passing and then
it's going to have to make a bunch of
changes and fix the tests again. Trust
me.
>> Okay,
>> we're working on the plan. Um, we're
only doing phase one. Um, I did one
small update to the plan. So, um, check
what's been done and then, um, update
the validation logic and then just run
the automated verification steps from
the plan. Don't use make. Don't read the
make file. Just run the cargo test
commands as documented.
>> H interesting. Send it.
>> I got to give it the plan path.
>> Did you stop the other one? Oh,
>> so we're paraly Yeah, we're paralyzing
here, but we're paralyzing between phase
one and also iterating on phase two.
>> Cool. So, it's going to run. I guess
it's going to run stuff, I guess. Auto
approve everything. Okay, cool. Let me
keep reading. I know why this error
handling is happening incorrectly.
The reason that this is happening is
this should actually be done in phase
that should be handled in phase three
later, not in phase one. So we don't
actually have to use exposed error yet.
>> We're already in we're already in phase
three here.
>> No, in the implementation that's phase
two. Yeah, like the error go down.
>> Yeah,
>> go down a little bit more. Go down a
little bit more. Oh, go down. Oh, it's
during time implementation. Okay,
>> I think it's decided that there's no
extra stuff to do. It's already It's
already done.
>> All right, cool. Let's go down.
>> You want to look at timeout
implementation?
>> Yes. Cool. That's correct. Don't set a
timeout. Okay, that's correct. Um, don't
do any of the WAMOM stuff. Tell it tell
ignore WASOM
in phase three.
>> Well, now this is trying to do a bunch
of stuff in phase. Which phase is this?
In phase three.
>> Uh, let's just see what it did.
And then I think so we're what? We're in
uh 11:42. So it's been about an hour and
45 minutes
>> since we've been doing this.
>> Um okay. So this is the actual error
detection happening here. Um
where we're like updating the enum.
Basically, we're adding timeout to the
error code. Even this seems correct
because we're going to like emit this
from inside the actual like client
handling.
>> Okay, I'm down for that.
>> Okay, so yeah, if we Yeah. Okay,
>> cool. That makes sense.
>> Use the message. Otherwise, we parse the
HTTP error.
>> We go up.
>> Yep.
>> I want to read a couple more things.
>> Yeah,
>> the timeout error will need to have uh
the client name as well.
>> Which phase is this? I missed the
outline. Can I get an outline?
>> No, you can just get an outline. It's on
the right side. Uh it's one of those it
is that one. Click on that the right
side. That icon that you had the
sidebar.
Nope. And then at the top. Yeah, that
one.
>> Yeah. Okay, cool. Oh, that's so much
better. Okay, cool. So, in phase three,
sorry, it was the
>> section four.
>> Phase 3.4.
>> Uh, section five.
>> Oh, that one.
>> This one.
>> The create errors. This part needs the
client name as well.
>> It needs the client information as well.
Since uh specifically you can tell it
since timeout error extends from client
http client error.
>> Cool. Let's go on. Um yeah, I'm just
going to check on this one.
Okay, that looks good. It's running the
test. It's making some
some fixes based on some parsing errors.
So this is the other thing that's really
important is like the better your test,
the more you can give the model an
objective measure of whether it's
correct or not. A lot of people talk
about like LM as judge or code review
agents and it's like the LMS are bad at
judging things if you ask me, but they
are good at reading errors and fixing
them. Um, and this is also why like you
don't necessarily always want to obsess
over getting the plan perfect. Um, you
just you just need to be get be good
enough to get the LM into this state
where it's it has structuring the right
code. It's putting the right things in
the right places. It's using the right
libraries and the right implementations.
And then if there's syntax errors or the
wrong method is used here, it's not
cloned properly, then then the model can
fix all that.
>> Yes.
>> Cool.
>> Let's keep reading.
>> Um, we'll let that one keep running.
We'll go back to our plan iteration
session. Um, looks like that did it
correctly.
Um, let's find that clone.
>> Yeah.
>> Um, yeah. Client name client.clone. That
looks right.
>> Yes, that looks correct.
>> Cool. And then the composite client
total timeout.
>> Um, this part is the part that scares
me. So, honestly, part of me is like
because I actually don't know how to
implement this. So, let me just um look
at this. Um, go down.
Okay, I guess sleep until deadline.
That's great. Never completes if no
deadline. I mean, this will probably
work. I think this will probably work.
>> This is all existing code pretty much,
right?
>> Yes.
says or however client name is accessed.
Should we have it go put that make that
correct or you fine to have it fix that
during the test cycle?
>> Um I think that that's actually correct.
>> Okay, cool.
>> I'm trying to remember in my code.
>> Yeah, if you're like I'm not sure then
we can have it go do a little bit more
research on the side and figure that
out. Um but that's like yeah for
pinpoint research then you can just
steer to the sub agents. You don't have
to go create a new research document.
Part of me is also thinking that we
should actually ignore composite uh
composite clients for now.
>> For now, just to simplify the plan.
>> Just to simplify the plan like uh like
for now let's just make sure that the
actual errors work for like primitive
clients.
>> Okay. So let's move the composite client
timeouts implementation
>> retry
>> timeout retry implementation into its
own phase after phase three.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah.
>> Yes. I feel way better about that. Um,
just because like I'm like I don't know
how the stuff is going to work. I want
to be able to get errors fully working
for like perfect timeouts.
>> And when you start building like the
other thing is too is you're going to
learn things as you do the
implementation plan. And so like the
smaller you can make your phases the
more you can be like cool we're going to
implement phase one and get that working
and then we're going to go from there.
And um
>> how do I say it?
You may have learnings that cause you to
change the rest of your plan in in the
in the earlier in the earlier phases.
>> Can we go see the other one? See if it's
done.
>> Yeah, let's take a look.
>> It is.
>> Says it's done.
>> Okay. So, here's here's how I know what
to do now. What I know now is I want to
go look at the validation files that it
created. I'm actually not even going to
look at the diff. Let's just look at the
validation file.
>> This is the thing is like yeah, if you
can if you can read the tests and you
know they work, then you don't actually
have to read every line of code. This is
the really powerful bit. It's in uh it's
in Baml. It's on BAML runtime. It's in
BAML lib
uh client. Yeah. So, it made some of
these. I don't know which ones it made,
but it made some.
>> It should have. If it didn't make these,
we know we're here. Here we go.
>> Here's the new ones.
>> Okay. Can you Can you disable the syntax
here?
>> I don't know how to do that.
>> Okay. Well, I don't know either. That
won't do it either. Um Oh, just select a
different file extension like text. The
LSP is always going to pick it. Okay.
Well, command. Never mind.
>> There we go. LSP still serves it. It's
good.
>> Oh, no.
>> It's fine. It's fine. I'll just ignore
it regardless. Um, yeah, there's one
pain point that we have to deal with in
our repo and we've got configurations
set up.
>> But let's just go read this. So, we have
a client. We do this and then we do
this. Cool. It says what? What's the
error? Unsupported property http. That
looks like a bad error.
>> Yeah, that looks wrong. It didn't
actually pull it in.
Yes. Unsupported property HTTP. Go on.
Let's read the next one. What does that
say?
>> Unrecognized fields and configuration
block connect time. This is for the
typo.
>> Yes. Um uh can you can you actually tell
it to s make a recommendation for what
thing to make? I don't like this error.
>> Um
>> it should recommend a we
always like Yeah, you should paste just
paste the error.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> And just say I prefer Yeah. and just say
I prefer a error that recommends
>> Here it is.
>> Wait, why did that not work?
>> It's here. It's just I was wrapped.
>> Wait, what does it say? First token
connect timeout. MS. Wait, why does it
say connect timeout? That is valid.
>> There's a timeout. There's a typo here.
>> What's a typo?
>> Typo is there's only one N in connect.
>> Oh, okay.
Can you actually tell it though? Give a
recommendation on best match. Yes. And
we have some functions to already do
that. Um, can you do me a favor? Um,
it's fine.
>> I'm I'm uh giving you the gift of gift
of taste.
>> Okay. Well, go back.
>> Okay. You want to read some more?
>> Yep.
>> That looks good. And again, these
examples execute, right? When you run
cargo test, it actually like makes sure
these errors match.
>> This is good. This should be a map. This
is fantastic.
Error for Oh, what does it say?
>> Total timeout is not supported in like
lowle. This is only for composite
clients.
>> Yes.
Cool. Unsupported property http. We
should
>> So some of these didn't work.
>> Yes. So we should figure out why. Oh,
it's because validation for uh those
clients are different. So we should tell
it that.
>> Okay. So the error in this file is
incorrect. Um the validation for the
orchestrator clients is different. Um,
and so we need to make sure that HTTP is
supported in those as well.
>> It's for fallback. It's just a composite
clients and like this is just like if
you have a good testing framework, this
is much faster to test because I know
for sure that the code is running and
parsing everything accordingly.
>> Yep. Okay. We're getting high in context
as well. So, um, I am
>> This takes a while to run the test. I'm
going to have to restart it. It's still
it's still doing the previous thing, so
I don't I don't want to interrupt it.
>> Cool.
So at this point what we have is we kind
of have we have the parsing working. We
have the data plumbed through the right
classes probably and I say probably
because I haven't actually looked at the
code but I do know the parsing is
working and like we've plumbed through
the most important part which is like
user syntax into the data model.
>> Yep. Can kind of skim through here.
Cool. Building programming languages is
fun.
>> Yeah. It's interesting at the very
least.
>> Is it normal for this to have no output?
>> Yeah.
>> Because we did a grab. Yeah. Okay.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Cool. Our new er Yeah, the tests are
failing because our new error messages
are different. So, it's going to run it
with update expect. Let's see what the
new error messages look like.
Yeah. Look at that. We got our fuzzy
finding working.
>> Yeah, it
>> this looks better, right?
>> It's slightly better. There's still
better things I would do, but I'm okay
with this for now.
>> Okay. I mean, that that's the kind of
thing that's probably We've seen that
it's easy to polish that part. Cool. I
just I would just let the last I would
just let the last thing rip even though
I
>> Yeah. Yeah. No, I I sent it.
>> Okay, cool. Just going to go work on
that. Um here's our planeration.
>> So, new structure, parse and validate,
define error types, implement basic
timeouts, implement composite timeouts,
implement streaming timeouts, testing
and documentation, runtime
configuration.
>> Yes, good.
>> I actually will probably do streaming
phase five before phase four. That's
actually the only difference I'd make.
And the idea is like I want to get the
primitive clients fully working end to
end
>> before I touch anything about the
composite client. This also makes
testing a lot easier.
>> So that's another guideline. Um changing
spec. Um we'll have it like guidelines
to add to create plan.md. This is the
thing you should always be doing when
you're working with this and you find a
thing like oh I always want the model to
do things X way. Then you want to move
it into your infrastructure which is
your your commands and your agents. Um
so number one was
guidance on cargo test generating new
error messages
tests etc. And then the other one was
always implement basic HTTP then
streaming then composite clients in that
order.
>> Yep.
>> But I I I personally probably wouldn't
put this in cloud MD because it's so
specific to this thing.
Yeah, there's some there's somewhere
where you might want to write this down
or keep it handy. We're also like you
may have like prompt snippets that you
store and that's just a thing whenever
you're changing the HTTP client logic.
Okay. So, yeah. Okay. Basic timeout,
streaming timeouts, composite client,
testing and docs, runtime configuration.
I don't know what phase 7 is, but we'll
get there. All right. You want to read
phase four then?
>> Yes, please.
>> Cool. Time to first token and idle
timeout. Here we go.
>> Okay, this looks pretty good. H. Okay, I
see. Okay. Yep, that looks good.
>> Literally counting clocks. Clocks are
hard. Okay. So, if this resolves and we
haven't gotten a token, then we go.
Otherwise, it's the other one.
>> Yep.
>> Cool.
>> Otherwise, we just get the next token.
We just keep alive.
>> Yeah. Okay. So, then we set this, then
we have to keep alive.
>> Cool.
>> Yep.
>> Cool. And yeah, look, I like how it's
staying brief here. Cool. And then in
each client we have to pass in the HTTP
config to the stream handler.
Okay,
sounds good.
>> This looks good to me.
>> Okay, I think we're still on phase one
over here, but I'm just going to do
infinite bypass.
>> Yeah. And then there is a technical
design thing that I need to think about
which is how do what do we want
fallbacks to do on certain types of
errors? And I think we want the
fallbacks to treat like time to first
token errors like errors that it just
like timeout errors are like things that
fallbacks consume and don't forward up.
You just get told that a timeout happens
and then you just move forward. So I
need to think about how composits will
play into that. But I think this will
just work as is right now.
>> Um sorry. So it's like how do composite
clients happen handle timeouts from
children?
>> Exact. And it's not just composit, it's
like retry policies as well. Cuz one
thing you could say is we want to error
out completely
on this. But I think what we're going to
do with timeout errors is uh is not what
we do with abort. On abort
we want to exit fully.
>> Yeah.
>> Timeouts we don't.
>> Yeah. I think a timeout Well, so
sometimes a timeout is like I want to
guarantee that I actually get a response
to the user in some amount of time. But
I think in general, yeah, timeouts are
retriable if it's if you're dealing with
like shoddy upstream infrastructure.
>> Yeah, exactly. Um, and then this should
almost be done.
>> So, let's see. It's doing the
expectations now.
>> Yeah, it's doing the other one where
it's actually running like the HTTP one
>> generated two warnings.
>> Problem with Rust, honestly, is the
worst part about Rust is yes, while it
compiles, it does work.
>> Uh, it is kind of slow to compile. Not
allowed for composite unsupported
property. Yeah, this one's still wrong.
Unsupported property. Yeah, it's still
not figuring this out. So, we've given
it feedback and it hasn't figured it
out. And so, my take here is we actually
need to go update the plan more
um or add like a phase 1B that is like
fix this thing before we move on.
>> Yeah.
>> You see what I mean? Like the composite
clients are still not able to fix this.
Yes,
>> this is correct. But this one on
supported property is still the error.
It looks like something actually died
and it didn't make the updates.
>> Okay. Well, while this is running, we'll
see how this runs.
>> Yep. Most tests are passing. All
validation tests are now passing. Oh,
this is valid. Great. Type field name
not allowed for composite. Okay, this is
better. This is the right error. This is
not failing on HTTP now. So, it did fix
it.
>> Exactly.
>> Okay, cool.
>> Um,
>> amazing. I'm going to commit this. do
it. And that's good. That's a good thing
to commit. So, like now we're done.
We're phase one.
>> Yep. And I will leave the I will leave
all the files and specs and stuff in
there. You can go clean them out of the
PR if you want to.
>> Yeah, I will do that. Can you can you
show the phase one so people can see
what the what the check boxes did?
>> Yeah.
>> Yep. And so it actually will check the
system will actually automatically check
off these stuff for you so you actually
know what you're done.
>> I actually just I Go ahead. I was going
to say and the the implement plan prompt
has a little bit of extra steering in it
to basically like make it able to
resume. So it's like if it has existing
check marks, trust that that's done,
pick up from the first unchecked item
and verify previous work only if
something seems off.
>> Yeah, exactly. So if we go back and take
a look at this, uh we can remove the
manual manual verification. We're done.
Or check it off yourself and probably
want to delete stop here for human
input.
>> Yeah. Okay, let's go compile the rest of
this. Can we look at the compilation
steps in error type definitions?
>> The Oh, the verification steps. It's
going to try to run this with make
again.
>> Yes. So, you should tell it how to do
this.
>> Sorry. I'm just going to do this.
>> Okay. Yeah. I didn't know that you make
so aggressively in your code.
>> I like make because it's language
independent and we use a lot of
different languages.
>> We do too, but it's interesting. I wish
there was a way to just not load
this because now your make file is going
to be not have all your stuff that you
need.
>> That's fine. I'm going to keep this one
in. Yeah, this this shouldn't be in my
global thing anyways. That's better.
Cool. There's your secret alpha for the
day is snippets of my claw MD.
>> There you go. Um, cool.
>> All right. So, uh, we use this commit
command that kind of splits things out
into logical files.
It's fine. I probably could have just
told it to just make one commit, but um
are you ready to jump to phase two?
>> I am. So, we just phase two.
>> Let's do it. Um we haven't read the
later phases, but we'll kick that off
and then we'll go back and read the f
the later phases of the plan. Cool. So,
um
BAML 1630 phase 2
only doing phase two. I guess that's
fine.
>> That's probably good. Let's rip, baby.
You got this.
>> Um, you might also want to tell it
something else. Um, yep. Which is the
way that you we run tests. So, let me
send that to you in Slack. So, that way
you have that for Python.
>> Um, yeah. Actually, we should up before
we start this, we should update the plan
to have that. You want to slack it to
me?
>> Yes. Um, I will give this to you. I'm
giving it to you. One second,
>> Elder. For your question about Sonnet 45
versus Opus. Sonet45 writes good code,
but when you want to reason over a long
complex codebase, you really want to be
using Opus most most of the time.
>> All right, I sent it to you. This is how
we run uh let me let tell you how we run
then uh and just tell it to not run the
typescript test. It'll just take too
long.
>> Are we also doing cargo test?
>> Yes.
>> Yes. Uh we don't really Yeah, probably
to just compile check like the previous
test should still pass.
>> Yep. Okay, cool. Cool. Yeah. So, we'll
update that in the plan and then we have
a look.
Cargo build, cargo test,
do this, do this, do this.
Do you want to do the rough check?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> That's how you check that everything is
compile time working.
>> Do you want to do the build here or skip
all Typescript?
>> Just skip all Typescript. Uh, yeah,
exactly.
>> I assume if we weren't on a stream, you
would run the TypeScript tests.
No, I'd probably not. If it it's like if
Python compiles and TypeScript doesn't
compile, it's really rare. It's probably
good enough. I'd run it at the very end
because again, my most my most important
resource is my time. So like I'm
optimizing for my time here. So like I
have a pretty good proxy that the test
will probably pass. And I know I'm going
to run.
>> If the Python's good, then you know the
TypeScript's good.
>> Yeah. And I know I'm going to run the
test eventually. So it's like it's not
like I'm not going to do it.
>> Cool.
Amazing. No, I run cloud code directly
on my machine. And the reason is like
honestly even if I'm using Opus, I am
still restricted to the directory I'm
operating in. So it's okay. If the model
does end up doing something really
malicious, I think you could just like
prevent certain you could just like
blacklist certain commands.
So like for example, I know Dexter did
something interesting. You type Python
into your shell, Dexter.
>> Uh oh, I had to get rid of that.
>> Okay. Uh, but yeah, I had a
>> Dexter had a command where if you typed
in Python directly into your shell, it
would it would shim it. Um, it would
shim Python to say echo use uh UV
instead to make sure that the model
could never do anything wrong.
Um, and that helped a lot
>> because there's Python in the cloud
default system prompt.
>> Yes.
>> But now if I run Python,
>> get the reload source.
>> It's in there. It's because the first
one isn't found. It's not a real thing.
You have double slash that goes to root.
>> Ah, all right. Well, I'm not going to go
messing around with my files. But yes,
there that's that's the basic idea is
you just replace Python. The first thing
in your path should be something else.
>> Yeah, that way if the model does it just
will not trigger the wrong Python. So I
think it's the same for all cloud code
stuff.
>> Yep.
Okay. So this one is ripping. That said,
I have had a friend who actually had
claude code or cur I think cursor
actually not cla code
>> run rm-rf
>> uh in a very scary scary directory in
the home directory tilda slash.
>> Yeah, you shouldn't do that.
>> And it did that because it actually made
a directory called tilda by accident in
the local folder and then it started
running that as a shell command to
delete that directory and that is um not
good.
>> Do not want that. Yes. Internal
monkeypatch.py.
>> Yeah, we've done some interesting stuff.
>> Does look right.
>> Yeah, I mean that stuff looks right.
>> Yeah. Okay. Um, cool. We are at hour two
and we're getting through it. Um,
we should think about what's next.
>> I think what's going to end up happening
is we'll get the timeout implementation.
Um, and I think it should work for the
connect and request timeout.
>> Mhm. Um
like as long as time out can if you can
you can you go back let's just make sure
timeout request is actually
>> this base three stuff
>> is only doing the basic stuff. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
So here's our HTTP client. We've read
that a bunch. Here's our request
implementation
and then we do that for all the
providers
and then we detect timeout errors in the
execution.
>> Yeah. Cool. That's correct. We should
get rid of the was on the stuff there.
Get rid of the wom stuff.
>> Yeah, we don't need it. It'll just work.
>> Let's remove the wom stuff from phase
three. Just leave it out of
>> Yep.
>> This is crazy.
>> It's going to distract it.
>> Um,
>> can you go up really fast? I want to see
a couple more things. I want to read
this error code. Detecting timeouts. Go
down. I want to read this.
>> Um,
request timeout. Error code timeout.
That's good.
>> Okay.
>> Yep. Okay. Otherwise, we just do one
from the status.
>> Oh [__] What was the code there before?
Can you command Z this? I might have
messed up. Maybe we did one.
>> Uh, we can go see what the diff was.
>> Oh, no. We do want that WASM stuff. I
was wrong. Oh, this is undo. That was
the original code in there. I thought it
added for this spec, but that's actually
the original code in there.
>> Yeah, sometimes it's not 100% clear what
it's it's like. It'll reproduce large
blocks of the code. It's not always
clear. I think this is the only thing
that's added. Is this it? Let else.
>> Yes, exactly.
>> Um, cool. And then is fine.
>> Yeah, that's fine.
>> Um,
okay. Let's scroll down.
This looks good. Timeout error code, I
guess. 408. I don't know what's a what's
a timeout error code. Is that 408? HTB
request timeout, I guess. So,
>> I don't think it's an HTB code. Is it?
>> I don't know. I'm going to Google that.
>> There you go.
>> Hey. Yeah. Request timeout.
>> Okay. I've never seen this code before.
It's one of those
>> Well, HTV codes are very fascinating. I
don't know what they have.
>> Yeah.
>> Let's see the
>> one
>> handle time orchestrator.
All right. So, we get the response.
If we get a timeout response, then we
expose it as a client as a timeout.
>> Timeout error.
>> Perfect.
Otherwise, we do that. Otherwise, we do
that, which is perfect.
>> Cool.
>> Yeah. Does this look right?
>> Um,
I would add some more tests. I want
phase before we do streaming timeouts
like phase 3B
>> almost
>> should be add end to and a add a pi test
inside of intest Python. Well, I would
do phase 3B.
I would make a separate phase a integy
inside of in Yeah. Python test.
>> Yeah.
uh to validate the time matter at error.
>> Uh yeah, use a pattern finder agent to
see how this works
>> and then yeah and then also give it the
UV command that I gave you earlier to
actually run how uh yeah there you go.
>> Amazing. Um great I can see HTTP config
as a default. I'm wondering
okay yeah so we have done some tests now
and finding a bunch of issues that we're
going to go start. Wow, 300 lines of
errors.
>> Uh, this is the problem with Ross.
They'll figure it out.
>> Yeah. Okay, we're already very high in
the context window, so I might actually
stop it. There's a command I use called
slash continue.
>> I would let it I would let it go on for
for a little bit longer.
>> Nope, I'm not because they changed the
the compaction window. This is going to
compact in like the next two seconds.
So, we're going to do a manual
compaction.
um create a handoff prompt about where
we are and it should start with
slashimplement plan and include a ref to
the plan file. Fortunately, we might
compact as part of this, which would be
frustrating, but let's see if the
context goes back down. Yeah, see it
already compacted itself. [__] Oh, I
hate it. We're still going to do a
handoff and start over.
>> Okay,
>> so this is the prompt it's going to use.
Current status is mostly complete. Needs
final testing and verification. We did
all the stuff. Yes. Okay. Yes. So, we
have a CLI to code layer that I use that
basically lets you have human in loop
for your compaction because it's going
to run the CLI to launch the next
session.
>> So, Oh, it's just going to launch that
for you.
>> Exactly. Um, so you let the model create
the prompt and then it's going to use
the CLI to do it. Um, this is kind of a
thing I've been playing with recently
that I've been enjoying. It's kind of
somewhere in between clear and compact.
Um, but it's a nice form factor. So,
yeah, this launched another one. And now
we should have there's a state thing
here, but it created this new one.
>> That's cool.
>> Um, yeah. So, here's the prompt that the
other model generated. We're using
implement plan. Here's the plan. And
then, yeah, we go from there.
>> Nice.
>> Um, cool. Okay. So, phase two is
rocking. This one we're going to we're
going to we're going to axe.
Um, and this one is looking for Python
test patterns. So, I think it should
have found them. Oh, opus. Come on.
>> Are you out of opus?
>> No, they're API erroring. This is why
can't have nice things.
Let's see.
>> This is actually why I really like uh uh
uh codeex. So, it actually does not go
down as much.
>> Let's see.
Yeah. Okay, it's back. It's just a
little spotty. I am hoping that the
context from this agent from that took 3
minutes searching for patterns is going
to be available in our context window.
Yeah. Okay, cool. It says based on the
patterns I found. So, I think it did
find things.
That's good. Just going to tee up
another one in case we need to make more
changes. Oops. Yeah. Okay, that's fine.
Nope, it's not. I didn't mean to send
it. Front ends are hard. This one's
still cooking.
This one's
ready. Okay. So, major updates. So,
phase 3B integration testing for timeout
errors. How's this look?
>> Okay, that looks correct.
That looks correct. 50 m timeout. That
looks correct.
>> A 500word essay. Cool.
>> Um, and that should fail.
Uh, go down.
>> That's right. Provider open AI. Should
this be
>> That's fine. Okay.
>> Um, let's read this.
>> Yep. That should read time at Perfect.
Um,
>> nice.
>> You're going too fast. I was sorry
>> that one. Yes. Fails. Yep. Accounting
for overhead of any kind. Why not? That
makes sense.
>> Abort after delay. Abort should still um
>> should not be a timeout error. This is
abort takes precedence.
>> Yes.
AB uh because when does a timeout error
happen?
Oh yeah. Yeah.
>> Looks like 100 millconds takes a board
takes precedence. That's amazing. Yeah,
that's really good.
>> Gone. Synchronous. Yep.
We also time out in synchronous clients.
That's perfect.
Streaming. Streaming should also time
out. That is perfect. Um
>> and then we haven't implemented this.
>> Yep. That's correct. That's correct.
Include. This is the power of the
codebase pattern finder.
>> Yes.
>> Is like if you're like I need to do this
thing and I know it wasn't in the
research, you can just steer it, go find
the pattern and then use that.
>> Yes, that is correct.
>> Okay. Um and then updating the BAML
config for tests. So this is timeout
test clients. This is what gets used by
the Python test.
>> Yes,
that this part it'll figure out that
that part looks about right. Uh yeah,
there you go. It figured it out.
>> Cool. Sick.
All right. Um,
>> and I think this is kind of the point,
like if I didn't know that we needed
these phases, we could be endlessly
spinning for a while, but I'm like, "Oh,
I want the Rust code to compile, then I
want the Python test to compile."
>> It's the same way you would engineer if
you were writing the code yourself.
>> Exactly.
>> Um, I think phase two is done. What do
you want to look at to verify it
manually?
>> Um, just look at the diff in VS Code.
Please don't show me the git diff here.
I want to see what files changed. Show
me the tree version.
>> This? No. How do I show you the tree
version? View is tree. Okay, cool. So,
we got this. We got this.
>> Okay. Yeah, it's just doing some like
Oh, you didn't get the commit from last
time. Interesting. Okay, that's fine.
>> Looks like it didn't do all the
providers, but maybe is OpenAI is like
the base for everything.
>> Um, I think this just mixed it from last
time. It just fixed some compile bugs
that your git commit didn't get.
>> Yeah. Okay, this looks about right.
>> Patch. Yeah, here we go. Typescript
errors.
>> Silent so you guys don't see my hear my
text notifications all the time.
Um, okay. Cool. Cool. Uh, all right.
Let's start phase three.
>> Cool. And I think the really nice thing
that a lot of people underestimate in
this workflow is just like how how like
independent each step is. And like for
context, this input this feature as you
guys can tell is very nuanced. There's a
lot of stages to it and it would have
taken forever to implement this
>> and by forever I mean like it probably
would have taken an engineer on my team.
>> A couple days.
>> Yeah. One day maybe two days of time and
that would be like a good implement. I I
would be like very like I personally
would be satisfied if it took me two
days to go from like nothing to it
working end to end. If we can get this
thing working with me and Dex spending
three hours here, this is clearly a win.
And this is like while we're live
streaming and also like not even trying
to do other things and be super
optimized here.
>> I think it was just you and me and there
was no stream. We weren't taking
questions and trying to like talk
through the thought process. We could
use the downtime instead of explaining
what we're doing. We would use the
downtime to go like work a sec a
separate feature in parallel. Phase
three is about implementing the actual
timeout functionality.
Um and then timing wise I have this on
till 1. Um I'm having to like commit and
push what we get. We can either do a
part two next week or we you can pick
this and run with it yourself. I don't
know. I don't know what you want to do.
>> I think if we get this working end to
end Python, I'm actually very happy. If
this works, this means that
>> like the re other reason I broke this
out.
>> Yeah.
>> Is that I can actually ship this and
make it usable by users very early on
without putting the whole composite
features and everything else in there.
>> You would you would ship these new
fields even if they didn't work for
streaming and composite.
>> Well, the
>> I guess it's two separate features.
Exactly. So composite, it comes to a
separate feature. Exactly.
>> But I would actually ship it for
individual clients because that's still
worth it.
>> But you need language support for every
language and you'd need those fields to
work on every all three of those fields
to work in every in every path so that
you could document it.
>> So I would do I would do phase 3B phase
4 with the streaming support and then
I'd merge
>> and then you chip it.
>> Yes, that'd be enough. I don't need
everything all the way end to end
working. I don't need composite features
to work. What is this? Runtime
configuration and advanced features. Is
this nonsense?
>> No, this is correct.
>> Ah, okay. This is like the dynamic
client registry stuff.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> Oh, it's very
>> I would I would do this stuff. It's It
is very fast. It just plugs into our
codebase.
>> Um, most of what we have is actually
works really really simply with the
whole system. It's designed in that way
where it should be easy for AI to add
these features or humans to add these
features, which is why most sections you
see are very short. We spend a lot of
time on architecting our codebase. Like
there's I I would say if you're vibe
coding from scratch, this this approach
will probably not work as well because
your codebase has no like concrete
architecture. Like for example, you know
the place where it picked out the wrong
error
>> for the property types where it was
recommending messages.
>> Yeah.
>> I that's actually incorrect the way it's
done. We actually have a different way
of doing it that will actually give you
recommendations that we that's a
standard format that we have that says
here are all the options. Here's the
thing the user typed in. Pass in the
error. I don't want it to use a new
method. I wanted to use that original
method. I just don't want to side rail
the whole conversation to fix that.
>> Well, we got there eventually anyways.
>> No, it didn't because it didn't use the
original method. There's a method that
we have that you have to use that
actually does the formatting for you for
that kind of stuff.
>> Okay. But the actual error messages we
got are correct. So, you're saying it
just rewrote that logic itself
somewhere?
>> It rewrote the logic with a shittier
version of that logic.
>> Interesting.
>> I have good logic that is actually like
way more battle tested for a lot more
edge cases.
>> Okay.
So, that's kind of how I would that's
kind of how I would think about it
because it does a whole bunch of stuff
around preference and ordering and stuff
there.
>> Yeah.
>> Um, and I don't want that to be the
case.
>> Okay. But that's that's the kind of
thing that is like, okay, once we got
the whole thing plumbed in to end,
that's a really easy refactor.
>> Exactly. It's not even a refactor. It's
actually like I I will use AI to solve
that problem, too. But I just don't want
to lose what I don't want to do here is
I don't want to lose a train of thought
over the details that I know don't
really matter.
>> So, we're at 60 again. I'm starting to
get a little again context anxious.
>> Yeah, the problem with our codebase like
I said is massive.
>> Well, also this plan file is getting
quite long and so it's reading the
entire plan file to only like a lot of
this is like stuff that's already done
and working and it may even be worth
compacting the plan file.
>> I have found that that has led to worse
results than letting the context window
with autocompact personally.
>> Okay. Um, and like what I would really
do here is I'd probably do all the
request timeout with every single client
with um with sub agents. That's what I
probably would have done.
>> I'll have it actually go do the
implementation with sub agents and do
the testing with sub agents.
>> Yeah, that's probably what I would have
suggested is like better if you really
care about compaction. Like honestly, I
probably wouldn't even do compaction
here. I would just let it rip.
>> I'm going to compact cuz we got pretty
See, it already auto compact.
>> All right, we got 30 more minutes. I
think my goal is by the end of this 30
minutes it should fully run. I think
it's good to give it the other phases
because then if it has that it knows
what context it can do personally. Let's
keep running this thing.
>> Yeah, we'll just let this run. Um
it actually the only reason you can't
use sub agents here is very sad because
the sub agents are sadly uh cargo does a
lock on the system.
Can't lock. It's actually really
annoying. And also when you're updating
a codebase individually, it's very
annoying unless you have like separate
packages that you're testing in because
it's all within the same package. You
can't really do it in any more parallel
sadly.
And incremental compilation is not a
thing that Rust really has in a great
way sadly. Yeah, but I don't know how if
they'll be able to do it sadly.
Honestly, I actually spend very little
time thinking about what model to use
and I just let it rip and then if I run
into problems, then I will deal with it.
Well, Sonnet 4.5 is supposed to be good,
so it's I think it's worth it. I
actually think people underestimate how
important speed is. I think most models
can write code pretty well. So, like I
probably would use Sonnet 45 or even the
smaller. I actually use the uh the
shittier Sonnet models all the time.
They're good enough. your your
philosophy of you use opus always like
personally I have a pretty good proxy of
when to use and when not to and I get
really results without using opus I
think it can do way harder problems than
that too personally yeah I don't know
that's just my personal take though like
I found it to be fine even for really
hard problems like super long
it is all vibes too no
it's I think most prompting in my honest
opinion most prompting whether it be at
the application layer or using coding
agents is all vibes. And the best thing
you can do is build a really really good
vibe checker in your own brain of
whether or not it's working or not. And
if you can do that, you that will likely
be better than any system you build
because there's this infinite there's
always this joke of like I spent I spent
four hours automating a 10-minute task.
I think the same with prompting for most
tasks. You're going to spend weeks
setting up an eval system for what was a
one day prompting problem. And the
infrastructure is not worth it most of
the time.
>> Well, no screen share. Yeah, because
there's literally just nothing to do. It
just you just have to wait through the
code.
>> Yeah. So, I'll tell you like my take on
this. So, like I've tried showing my
team the prompts and usually what I find
is any workflow that I give to my whole
team, engineering is such a diverse
medium that you usually don't have one
thing that fits all. Um, and like for
example, we all use VS Code. We all use
VS Code in totally different ways. We
all have terminals. We all use terminals
in totally different ways. Then the
reason VS code and terminals I think
work really simply is because like
there's one medium that they have which
is like reading and editing files which
is a really really common pattern but
the actual mechanism that you use to
read and edit files is varies
dramatically between every single
engineer I've ever met. So like or just
like for example you use Vim keybindings
I use I use regular keyboard key
bindings like engineering is such a
dynamic discipline that there's no one
homogeneous way to do things for almost
every task. uh we have workflows like
system workflows like GitHub pull
requests and everything that we do
clearly have more systematic ways of
doing things usually but even then every
team has different ways of doing this
and it's not really prescriptive but
it's usually just like hey thou thou
shalt code review thou shalt do certain
things but not really how the how is
very loosely defined
and I think for prompting and everything
else like as hard as I tried to get my
engineers to do all be do the same exact
thing actually turns out that they're
better when they're doing the thing that
is like kind of like a an offshoot off
of the golden path that works for them
and makes them happy and enjoy the work.
>> And then same with prompts like I think
there are prompts that certain engineers
like because their workflow is better.
It works with their personal style of
workflow better. So that was like I
think one of the key learnings that I've
had which is like and if I press one
workflow on one uh on people too much
then they won't really have fun anymore.
And part of software is not just like
being a machine that spits out code.
It's actually like enjoying the work.
And that's almost like Yeah, it's like
coming to the conclusion yourself rather
than being told what to do. You made two
plans.
>> Okay, let's keep on going on the Let's
see where the implementation's at. Let's
see what it gets.
>> Yeah. Now, now it literally should just
do like a quick compilation step and
then we should read write some pi test.
And like honestly, if all the pi tests
pass, I'd be surprised. I'd probably run
it manually myself because I don't
really trust it. Once it tells me that
it passed, then I would just like see if
it actually passed. Just as a quick
sanity check, you know, I don't want I
don't want to be I don't want to be a
schmuck that just like is like, "Ah, the
AI told me it didn't." Like, while I do
kind of believe it, it's like uh for
really serious stuff, even if my
engineers say the code works, uh or any
team I've ever worked on, if someone
that I'm code reviewing said the code
works, for really serious stuff, I will
go validate it myself.
>> Exactly. Because I'm in the end, I'm
still on the hook for the code working
like regardless of like whether I wrote
the code or not. And like this is and I
didn't notice I didn't do it before for
the previous test because I trusted that
system a lot more than this one. This is
like an end toend test. I'm like ah I
don't want to think about it. Let's
really make sure that this works. But
sadly we just have to wait. I really
wish there was a better thing to do than
just wait. Um no I don't know that I
need to think about this more. That's
why also it's like there's a deeper
problem here that I need to think about
how to do. Um don't update greet plan. I
would Oh yeah. Okay. Oh, so you're not
going to auto approve. Interesting. But
yeah, I mean, you told it the wrong
thing, so it makes sense. It'll fix
them.
It's going to run. No, this is going to
run. I'm like, it's so close. As soon as
a pi test command runs, I trust me, I
think it's going to work. Uh, that part
is fast. It'll just compile. Once this
compiles, the Python test should just
work. It's going to be better than you
think. Um, so I'll stick on a little bit
longer just until we get the Python test
running. If we don't get the Python test
running on like within the first uh
three to four minutes of it executing
that space then we can call it. But I
think it will run. I'm very optimistic
actually. I think this workflow has
worked for me really really well.
Um and I think what's cool for everyone
here is like look I I know BAML. Dexter
doesn't like the BML codebase. And
really all we're doing here is I'm just
reading the plan. He's writing all the
code. I haven't I haven't touched a
single prompt. And like Dexter's
basically like paraphrase some of the
stuff that I've done, but in reality I
haven't done most of it. It's
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, it's fine. So why why do you do
the continue all the time?
>> Is that actually true? Are you sure it
deletes all the prompts and not just
like summarizes the last few messages in
some interesting way? Okay. Yeah, I
would just double check. I I suspect
that they they probably do something a
little bit more clever than just like
summarize everything here.
>> I think that's the one other thing that
I've learned about myself. Um, wait, why
does it say about Ruby FI? I mean, I
just don't care about compiling Ruby.
The autoco compact generates a summary
of about 3500 words. You can ask the new
agent what is the Damon fetched in
fetched in to write word for word the
transcript provide as file.
Uh, yeah, then you can see the autoco
compact. Yeah, I think it's because it's
just trying to do compilation stuff.
Yeah. Okay, now it's reading the plan.
That's good enough to be honest. That is
the core packet. If that packet passes,
then the rest of it will Yeah. Yeah.
Exactly. Yes. I'm very excited for this.
If this works, it's gonna be super
exciting. And again, I think what's
really fascinating about this whole
thing is like this is
so so so
much faster than the old workflow. Like
what like all this is going to do is
literally write the Python in tech test
and verify that the inte pass. Um, and
like if this works that means the whole
pipeline worked and now we now have like
timeouts at least for part of the
codebase like for primitive clients we
now have support for connection and uh
idle timeouts which are huge like
connection request timeouts. Yeah, the
built-in timeouts are whatever but like
this part I think is the most
fascinating like how does how well does
this work and if this works and like
it's it's golden in terms of like
outputs like this will work
fantastically. I don't know if it ran
the matcher command. Did it? Can you
scroll up and see?
It did. Oh, it did not go up.
Uh, tell you need to run the matchin
command. Matcher command. Just say
matcher. M a tu. Yeah, that one. Just
tell it. It'll figure it out. And then
you do need openi API key. Uh,
you do? I think so. So, you might want
to probably want to stop screen sharing.
Yeah,
>> because that's going to fail for a
variety of different reasons.
>> I have not.
>> Yeah. Nice. So this will
>> Yeah, we're actually working on fixing
this. So this is um much faster because
like pio3 and matcherin are just like
too slow. Yeah, exactly. So it'll fix
itself. I think we're going to be done
soon. I'm very optimistic. We'll see if
it pans out. Yep. Exactly. Yeah, the
diff. That's correct now. Yeah, it it'll
figure it out. This part I feel really
confident about. It probably had to read
the file and be like, "Oh yeah, exactly.
It got the better version of it." Yep.
Now that Python compiles, so we know
that the compilation works end to end.
Yep, I think all things should be in in
Rust. All dev tools should be built in
Rust. I have a strong opinion on that.
Well, dev tools application code write
in whatever you want, but like where
develop.
There we go.
That works. Run it yourself. Yeah. I
want to go run the test and I want to go
Oh, I mean, I guess we can just look. I
want to run the test with like a with
like a with a t thing.
Uh, do- Yeah.
Oh, it is dashv dash dash VVV. Oh, it
responded too fast.
Oh, I think so. What's the assertion
error that you got? Oh, it didn't. The
model just responded poorly. Uh, the
assert is bad. We should get rid of that
assert in that test
cuz the model is responding with like a
string by just knowing it's a string
more than 10 characters and that we
didn't fire an exception.
>> That's it. Like this works. There we
have it. Like end to end Python asserts
definitely work. We're getting time. If
we go look at the actual Can you open up
the thing for me really fast? The the
codebase so we can show the commits
uh the Python code. I want to show the
Python test file test. Yeah. Test
timeouts. Like we're definitely firing
these tests and we're definitely
capturing these exceptions. Now, it's
possible that there's still a bug here.
So I would have to go and like read this
code in really good detail, but just
statistically based on everything that
we have compiled and looking at the diff
of everything so far where the only
difference is really the client that
we're passing in. I find that hard to
believe.
>> So um maybe after I validate that it's
actually good myself. Cool. So Dex, if
you can take all the thoughts, take all
the research, take all of his stuff and
put it as a PR up uh if to the repo. Uh
we'll take it from here.
Um yeah, so this was like I said a
longer form episode compared to what we
normally do. Uh and what we will be
doing in back in the future is we'll go
back to writing more code. But today we
wrote a lot of code using AI and
hopefully the lessons that we shared
around here are going to be helpful to
all of you. With that, we're going to
peace out and let Dexter get the stuff
up and running. Thank you guys for
making all the time and tuning in. Uh
Dexter, until next time.
See you.